Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Was mich ja schon seit längerem beschäftigt, bin ich schon drin?
Drin. Das ist ja einfach.
Logbuch-Netzpolitik Nummer 261 vom 13. Juli 2018.
Freitag, den 13. Juli. Oh, stimmt. Ja.
Na, dann hoffe ich mal, dass wir irgendwelche schlechten Nachrichten haben.
Keine Sorge, haben wir. Aber ich kann auch sagen, wir fangen heute mit einer guten Nachricht an.
Ja, wir sind alle drin.
Aber...
Alle Kinder sind drin.
Man muss die guten Nachrichten nehmen, wie sie kommen.
Erstmal Feedback.
Erstmal noch ein paar Feedback.
Ich habe auch gerade gute Nachrichten.
Du hast auch gute Nachrichten. Buchhaltung fertig oder was?
Das E. Ich sage jetzt mit Konstanz alle großen Durchbrüche im astronomischen,
kosmologischen Bereich voraus, indem ich einfach immer zum richtigen Zeitpunkt
den Podcast zum Thema mache und dann kommt der Durchbruch.
Das heißt, du machst den immer zu früh, willst du sagen, weil du dann nicht den...
Also genau, einmal war ich hinterher mit den Gravitationswellen,
das hab ich dann halt einfach mal gecovert, als es passiert ist.
Und dann hatte ich aber irgendwie so einen Lauf und dann hab ich irgendwie erst
so Neutronensterne und dann gab's irgendwie so...
Neutronensterne gibt's aber schon länger.
Ja, aber man hat halt noch nie eine Kollision von zwei Neutronensternen beobachten
können und das kam dann irgendwie genau die Woche danach.
Wurde aber in dem Podcast...
Auf der B96A, ne?
Das war richtig schlimm.
Stundenlang die Tram nicht durchgekommen.
Ein Stau bis zum Mond.
Genau. Und jetzt gab es wieder einen Durchbruch. Jetzt gibt es irgendwie auch
noch neben Gravitationswellenastronomie gibt es jetzt auch noch Neutrino.
Neutrino waren die Teile, die man nicht observen konnte, ne?
Die sehr schwer zu beobachten sind, weil sie einfach mal Klein, schnell, ungeladen.
Ja, und wollen irgendwie mit nichts richtig interagieren. So ein bisschen wie Bundesregierung.
Und ja, dann haben sie da irgendwie so einen großen Detektor in der Antarktis
gebaut und dann dachte ich mir, das ist doch mal ein geiles Thema und jetzt, tada,
haben sie halt irgendwie Neutrinos von so einem supermassiven schwarzen Loch
irgendwie empfangen und das ist der
große Durchbruch in der Multimessenger-Astronomie und wer hat's gecovert?
Tim Prillaf. Im Raumzeit-Podcast. Poliziz-Podcast.
Ja, wunderbar. Haben wir verlinkt. Höre ich mir dann auch Zeitnah an.
Die ist vom 6. Juni? Dann habe ich die ja schon gehört.
Hier steht, veröffentlicht am 6. Juni 2018.
Genau. Erst kommt die Sendung, dann kommt der Durchbruch.
Erst kommt die Sendung, dann kommt der Durchbruch.
Das wirkt so als Durchbruchskatalysator.
Kommen wir zum Feedback.
Kommen wir zum Feedback. Julian sagt, dass das Parlament noch nie einen Ausschussentwurf
abgelehnt hätte, ist definitiv falsch.
Netzpolitische Präzedenz gab
es da zum Beispiel 2006, als das Plenum gegen Software-Patente stimmte.
Wir haben versucht da noch Daten zuzufinden und es scheint tatsächlich so zu sein.
Genau, wir haben jetzt noch nicht so richtig den alles überzeugenden Link, aber passt schon.
Mir fällt ein, vielleicht sollten wir noch ganz kurz unseren Gast vorstellen.
Höflichkeit gebietet es, dass der Gast auch zu Wort kommt.
Wir begrüßen André Meister mit einem wunderschönen T-Shirt an von Atari Teenage Riot.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, das ist sogar echt so angegriffen. Das ist wirklich
retro, das ist nicht retro gekauft.
Das ist ein paar Jahre schon älter, ja.
Keep the Internet free from government control. Ja, da kommen wir gleich zu.
Hallo.
André ist wieder da, bekannt aus Funk und Fernsehen und Landesverrat und Netzpolitik.org.
Lange nicht mehr hier gewesen, oder?
Ja, letzte Woche, aber erst nach der Sendung. Aber ich war lange nicht mehr
in der Sendung. War ja auch wieder weg im Winter.
Winter reden wir gleich auch noch mal.
Die Software-Patente, um zum Thema Thema zu kommen, wurden tatsächlich,
glaube ich, vom Plenum abgelehnt. Unsere Frage vorhin war, ob vorher der jeweilige
federführende Ausschuss dem zugestimmt hat und sich das Plenum gegen den Ausschuss gestellt hat.
Das haben wir jetzt nicht sofort ergoogelt.
Bei ACTA war es so, das Plenum hat das auch abgelehnt, aber da waren auch die
Ausschüsse schon dagegen.
Genau. Und der entscheidende Punkt war, dass sich das Parlament gegen den Ausschussentwurf,
bewegt. Aber Julian meint, das wäre da der Fall gewesen.
Julian wird das wissen. Wir nehmen das jetzt einfach mal so hin und wenn es
nicht stimmt, wird das Internet schon reagieren.
Wenn es nicht stimmt, wird es in der nächsten Sendung von jemand anderem korrigiert werden.
Ich habe gehört, das ist das Sendungskonzept. Einfach mal behaupten und aufstellen.
In den Kommentaren wird das schon gefixt.
Internet-Basis-Wissen. Wenn du die Antwort auf eine Frage suchst,
ist die Lösung nicht, im Internet die Frage zu stellen.
Die Lösung ist, eine falsche Antwort ins Internet zu schreiben,
weil da wird garantiert jemand kommen, der dich korrigiert. So funktioniert das mit dem Internet.
Someone was wrong on the Internet.
Deswegen versuchen ja die ganze Zeit die Leute mit ihren Verschwörungstheorien.
Kommen wir auch noch zu.
Haben wir alles einen bunten Strauß.
Dann ein Kommentar von Hase, etwas lang, ich nehme nur Ausschnitte.
Im Beitrag kam die Frage auf, inwieweit Polizei und Staatsanwaltschaft Auskünfte bzw.
Kontoauszüge von Banken erhalten können. Hierzu die Sicht aus einer mittelständischen Bank.
Als Faustregel kann man sagen, sobald es ein Strafverfahren gibt,
müssen Bankangestellte aussagen.
Es gibt dann kein Zeugnisverweigerungsrecht, Details, pipapo.
Die Polizei kann also Bankanstalt zur Vernehmung vorladen und selbstverständlich
kann die Staatsanwaltschaft auch in der Bank eine Hausdurchsuchung durchführen lassen.
Zweitens, Versiegelung von Unterlagen kann, das war auch kurz Frage,
dass wir nicht genau wussten, wie das gemacht wird.
Antwort kann zum Beispiel ganz einfach mittels Klebesiegel erfolgen.
Die Unterlagen müssen in eine Box, diese wird mit dem Siegel verklebt.
Damit kann man auch ganze Räume versiegeln, indem man diese abschließt und das
Siegel über das Schloss klebt. Siegelbruch ist ein Straftatbestand und da gibt
es auch ein Bild von einer versiegelten Tür.
Ja, das ist dann so ein roter Aufkleber vom Band, amtliches Siegel und dann
wird von Hand mit Kugelschreiber,
Datum und so weiter draufgeschrieben von der oder diejenigen,
die das Ding versiegelt haben.
Ansonsten noch, im Beitrag wurde erwähnt, dass ein früheres Vorstandsmitglied
des Vereins, das noch Kontovollmacht hatte, in das Visier der Ermittler kam.
Das könnte die Polizei über eine Auskunft zusammen mit der Anforderung von Kontoauszügen
bei der Bank in Erfahrung gebracht haben.
Oder über eine Anfrage in der nach meiner Erfahrung wenig bekannten Datenbank
aller Konten in Deutschland inklusive Verfügungsberechtigten.
Vergleiche Paragraph 24c KWG, automatisierter Abruf von Kontoinformationen.
Das haben die Cops damals bei Landesverrat auch bei uns gemacht.
Eine Anfrage beim Einwohnermeldeamt und eben welche Kunden wir haben abgefragt.
Als allererstes, ehe sie irgendwie entschieden haben, erstmal doch nicht weiter
zu ermitteln. Aber das ist wohl echt eine Standardmaßnahme.
Tja, ich bin ja mit der Überwachung von Finanzsystemen generell habe ich so
ein zwiespältiges Verhältnis, ist, weil ich halt,
prinzipiell glaube, dass das primär halt tatsächlich,
wenn es das nicht gibt, halt vor allem kriminellen Betrügern und so weiter Politikern
und so dient und deswegen weiß ich gar nicht, ob ich das so,
Ob ich das jetzt so dramatisch finde, wenn es in dem Bereich die Möglichkeit
gibt, welche ja von genug Leuten mit Blockchain-Technologien aus der Welt geschafft werden kann.
Und ich sorge mich dabei darum, dass ich da am Ende nicht der Profiteur bin,
wenn diese Technologien in die Breite ausgerollt werden.
Also, dass das dann eher eben denen dient, die Kapital haben,
Steuern hinterziehen und Sonstiges.
Aber das ist, glaube ich, ein anderes Thema.
Wer gewinnt im Kapitalismus?
Ich glaube, ich weiß, wer da gewinnt. Das Kapital, aber nicht spoilern.
Dann kommentiert Roland S., auch hier nur ein Ausschnitt, ich finde es schade,
dass von den Moderatoren fast immer eine negative bis abwertende Haltung gegenüber
der Polizei durchscheint.
Gut. Wenn die in irgendwie sechs bis sieben Locations in unserem unmittelbaren
Freundes- und Aktivistenkreis rechtswidrige Durchsuchungen durchführen,
dann führt das natürlich zu einer etwas kritischen Haltung gegenüber der Polizei.
Wobei aber auch Moritz ja ganz klar gesagt hat, hier nicht der Polizei der Vorwurf zu machen ist,
sondern der Staatsanwaltschaft, die diese Maßnahmen hat beantragen lassen und
der Richterin oder dem Richter, ich weiß nicht genau wer es war,
der diesen Anträgen auch stattgegeben hat.
Prinzipiell finde ich die Idee gut, dass es eine Polizei gibt.
Das heißt also, die Idee, eine Grundhaltung hier zu haben, finde ich nicht gut.
Gut, bei uns in der Sendung wird eben in der Regel Polizei kritisiert.
Wir loben sie aber auch zum Beispiel für Fahndungserfolge, als sie nämlich ganz
ohne Vollüberwachung des Internets in der Lage waren,
den Waffenhändler für den bekloppten Rechten da in München gefunden haben mit
sauberer Polizeiarbeit.
Und ich denke, hier haben wir eine kritische Haltung gegenüber den Kompetenzen
und dem immer wieder stattfindenden Kompetenzmissbrauch,
unter dem eine ganze Reihe guter, ehrlicher und rechtschaffender Polizisten leider leiden muss.
Genau und das ist glaube ich auch so eine differenzierte Haltung,
die man einfach haben muss.
Die Erkenntnis einerseits, dass nicht jeder Polizist ist gleich,
sondern alle bewegen sich natürlich in dem vorgegebenen Rahmen und das ist sowohl
ein gesetzlicher Rahmen als auch ein kultureller Rahmen und dass manche in diesem
kulturellen Rahmen auch mal übers Ziel hinausschlagen ist allgemein bekannt,
aber dass auch der rechtliche Rahmen wackelt, wie man das jetzt bei den Polizeiaufgabengesetzen,
man muss ja jetzt schon Plural benutzen, droht oder sich jetzt auch schon abzieht.
Verzeichnet, das ist auch bekannt und wir hatten ja auch diese ausführliche
Sendung zu dem Polizeieinsatz rund um den G20 in Hamburg.
Wer das gehört hat, der, denke ich mal, sollte ja keine Probleme damit haben,
unsere Zurückhaltung bei der Bewertung der Aktivitäten der Polizei zu verstehen.
Weil das war einfach mal nun, ja ich will das jetzt nicht alles aufrollen,
aber wenn man sich die Sendung nochmal gibt, kommt man jetzt nicht unbedingt
so zu dem Eindruck, dass da immer alles in Ordnung ist.
Auch jetzt nicht. Ich möchte doch nochmal einen Satz sagen. Also die hatten
einen Versuchungsbeschluss von der Staatsanwaltschaft, aber da steht drin,
die dürfen Kontodaten aus diesem Jahr mitnehmen, die Rise Up betreffen und die
haben aber einmal alles mitgenommen.
Quasi mehr als in dem Versuchungsbeschluss steht. Die haben in Dortmund Leuten
gesagt, wenn du hier irgendwie rumzickst, dann kommen wir wieder und dann bist
du nicht mehr Zeuge, sondern Beschuldigter oder so.
Also Dortmund haben wir jetzt, in der letzten Sendung hatte ich das ja noch
kurz, nur kurz darauf Bezug genommen.
Wir haben jetzt inzwischen auch eine Pressemitteilung zu den Vorfällen in Dortmund,
also spezifisch nochmal im Chaos-Treff Dortmund.
Da ist halt einfach mal ganz offensichtlich Rechtswidriges vorgefallen.
Der Durchsuchungsbeschluss in Dortmund bezog sich nämlich nicht auf den Chaos-Treff Dortmund.
Die sind da reingegangen, haben denen über mehrere Stunden die Verwendung von
Telefonen und Rechnern untersagt, was nicht erlaubt ist.
Die dürfen nicht einfach ohne Durchsuchungsbeschluss bei dir reinkommen und
sagen, Telefon auf dem Tisch sitzen bleiben.
Nachher haben sie natürlich gesagt, die hätten ja auch gehen können.
Während die Polizei deinen Hackerspace durchsucht, kannst du natürlich auch gehen.
Haben dann irgendwie für die Dauer der Durchsuchung die Personalausweise weggenommen,
ihre Personalien aufgenommen und haben ihnen den Durchsuchungsbeschluss erst später gezeigt,
ihnen keine Kopie davon erlaubt, haben irgendwie Fotos gemacht und so weiter
und haben dann sich eben auch hier mit denen unterhalten.
Also auch in den Gesprächen, wir haben da als CCC natürlich viel uns auseinandergesetzt
mit unseren Freunden in Dortmund,
die dann auch in dieser Zeit eben in Gespräche verwickelt und unter anderem
sowas so, ja und wo arbeitest du denn und so und am Ende kamen dann die Drogenfreundchen,
ich wollte nur nochmal sagen,
wenn ihr euch irgendwie,
wenn ihr uns irgendwo in den Weg kommt.
Dann kommt ihr in irgendwelche polizeilichen Dateien, die ernste Konsequenzen
nach sich ziehen können und das könnte irgendwie auch sein, dass du deinen Job verlierst dann.
Also echt weirde Aktionen und ich denke da geht es eher um eine negative Haltung
gegenüber solchen Aktionen als gegenüber den einzelnen Polizisten.
Und bei Free.de, dem Projekt, das sie durchsucht haben, haben sie keine Zeugen
und keine Anwälte dazugelassen.
Ja.
Und sie hätten auch fragen können, ob sie die Tür aufmachen können,
statt die raus zu, aus den Angeln zu heben und aufzubrechen.
Ja, all das wäre möglich gewesen, haben sie darauf verzichtet und da müssen wir uns gegen wehren.
Gut, aber da sind sie, die guten Nachrichten.
Die gute Nachricht, es gibt eine gute Nachricht, die wichtigste Nachricht.
In Klessengörne wurde 2018 eine provisorische Funkzelle errichtet.
Halleluja!
Das ist doch eine gute Nachricht.
Das ist eine gute Nachricht. Also wo ist Klessengörne? Du hast ja hier schon die Google-Mappe auf.
Das ist im Naturpark Westhaveland, auch unweit des Sternenparks Westhaveland.
Westhaveland, das ist, sagen wir mal, eine Gegend, die durch Abwesenheit von
urbaner Infrastruktur glänzt auch.
Also für so einen Sternenpark ist das ja mal ganz gut, dass da schön dunkel
ist und nicht so viele Lampen rumstehen etc. pp.
Nur von Internet hat da keiner was gesagt.
Also schlechte Nachrichten für die Wavys im Naturpark Westhaveland.
Ich glaube sogar, dass ich da mal, genau, da wollte ich sagen,
da ist nämlich das traditionsreiche Dorf mit dem Namen Kotzen.
Mit dem schönen Bild bei Google. Vor dem Orts-Eingangsschild.
Okay, das ist natürlich auch klar, dass da jemand. Das Orts-Eingangsschild ist
zielregelmäßiger Fotos.
Selfies.
Ja, da fahre ich tatsächlich lang, das kenne ich.
Wo ist das denn?
Korzen.
Korzen? Korzen ist bei Klessenkörne.
Das ist 70 Kilometer von der Hauptstadt Europa aus.
Zwischen, wenn du nämlich den Berlin-Havel-Radweg und dann den Elbe-Radweg fährst,
wie es ja meine Art ist, dann kommst du da vorbei in dieser Ecke.
Und ich kann bestätigen, da war kein Empfang.
Nicht mehr. Und spätestens seit dem Jahr 2000, würde ich sagen,
ist das eine Internetversorgungsleistung,
Weit unterdurchschnittlich ist. Und Mobilfunk hatten die nicht.
Es gab keinen Mobilfunk.
Ist nicht. Die konnten nach Hause gehen in ihr WLAN und mit 128 Kilobit irgendwie
eine WhatsApp-Nachricht über Nacht schicken.
Aber die konnten so, ich lasse das Telefon mal an, ich schicke noch eine WhatsApp-Nachricht.
Aber und jetzt wurde in einer wirklich an Absurdität nicht zu überbietenden
Aktion vom Infrastrukturminister Andreas Scheuer dort ein ganzer Bus Journalisten hingefahren,
anderthalb Stunden raus nach Klessengörne, Wo dann irgendwie mit Foto-Opportunity
der Technikvorstand der Deutschen Telekom,
Walter Goldenitz, der Infrastrukturminister Scheuer, der fröhliche Bürgermeister
Herr Tessinow und noch andere Leute von Amt und Würden,
feierlich auf einem Thinkpad, das jetzt auch nicht aussieht wie das neueste Modell.
Die Space-Taste drücken.
Das könnte dieses Jubiläums-Thinkpad sein oder einfach ein X200,
wie ich es auch noch pflege.
Auf jeden Fall jetzt nicht das mobilste Mobilgerät.
Inszenieren sie dann da den Knopfdruck, mit dem diese Funkzelle in Betrieb genommen wird.
Stellt sich raus, die haben da irgendwie als Volksfest inszeniert,
dass die sich nicht schämen,
Und am Ende des Artikels steht dann, ja, sind zwei provisorische Masten,
sieht man auch, glaube ich auf dem Bild, wenn ich das richtig sehe,
das ist halt so ein, also wie funktioniert ein provisorischer Mast?
Genau das Teil stand bei uns 1999 auf dem ersten Camp.
Ja, genau. Die bestellst du nämlich auf Festivals oder ich glaube bei der Republika
wird auch mal einer hingestellt, zumindest von den schwachen Infrastrukturanbietern.
Kann sein, aber die Telekom hat sowas halt im Fuhrpark und das können die mal irgendwo auffahren.
Ja, ist eine Anhängerkurve, kriegt dann rechts und links so Stützen, fährt einen Mast aus,
dieser Mast ist dann über Mikrowelle angebunden irgendwo anders hin,
das heißt da ist so eine Trommel dran, sieht aus wie so eine Blechtrommel,
das sind halt die Mikrowellenrichtantennen und die richtest du dann aus und
dann meldet die sich eben ein paar Kilometer weiter an und sagt Hallo. Hallo?
Und dann hast du dieses Ding angebunden.
So, jetzt frage ich mich, ist Klässengörne, ist die Bürgerwehr Klässengörne
darauf vorbereitet, dass das Ding da in 14 Tagen wieder weggeholt werden soll?
Und haben die vorgesorgt?
Haben die vielleicht das Ding inzwischen einfach mal in ein Fundament eingegossen,
damit das nicht mehr wegkommt?
Oder sowas, ja, da muss man ja vorsichtig sein, weil eine provisorische Funkantenne,
Denn nach ursprünglichem Plan des Zentralkomitees Landwirtschaftlicher Funkausbau
war das erst für 2020 gedacht.
Es ist doch unglaublich, was in Deutschland alles möglich ist.
Also man kann dann wirklich 10, 20 Jahre nachdem alle anderen schon durch die
Zielgerade, durchs Ziel gelaufen sind, kommt man dann auch irgendwann an.
Das aber auch nur, weil ein Fernsehsender aus Japan hergekommen ist und eine
Sendung darüber gemacht hat.
Die sind eine anderthalbe Stunde aus der Hauptstadt rausgefahren und hatten
kein Handy empfangen und haben gedacht, was ist denn hier los?
Das ist ja schlimmer als in Kasachstan, was es wohl laut manchen Statistiken auch ist.
Haben eine Sendung darüber gemacht und das war dem Bürgermeister der Region
und natürlich dem neuen Verkehrsminister peinlich und dem Verkehrsminister Scheuer
muss jetzt just einen Tag vor dem Mobilfunkgipfel in Berlin diese PR-Aktion
machen, damit der besser dasteht.
Japaner haben in ihrem Fernsehen darüber berichtet, dass in Christenburg gar kein Internet gibt.
In Deutschland, kurz außerhalb der Hauptstadt, fährst eine Stunde mit dem Bus bis zum Nichts.
Geil, das ist ungefähr so, als ob man dann hier so Bilder aus der dritten Welt sieht.
Ja, genau.
Jetzt gibt es hier ein Brunnenbohrprojekt, damit die Gemeinde endlich sich mit
frischem Wasser versorgen kann.
So muss das in Japan rüberkommen. Oh Gott.
Es ist einfach nicht zu verstehen, dass wir in diesem Land das irgendwie dulden.
Und wie das dazu kommt.
Das steht ja auch noch da. Der Funkmast ist ja nur provisorisch,
denn das Genehmigungsverfahren für den Bauantrag für den festen Mast, der läuft ja noch.
Ich bin mal gespannt, also die Gemeinde ist irgendwie so groß,
350 Einwohner, der Bürgermeister ist ehrenamtlich, das ist üblich in so kleinen Gemeinden.
Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, ob es da nicht irgendeine Behörde gibt,
irgendein Amt oder so, die da morgen hinfahren und irgendwie ein Strafzettel
dran kleben, weil das Ding irgendwie im Halteverbot steht oder so.
Ich fand dann auch die Meldung so geil, so ja, jetzt wollen sie die Mobilfunklöcher stopfen.
Brandenburg ist ein Mobilfunkloch.
Ja, aber ich meine, bitte, Mobilfunk war von Anfang an irgendwie angetreten
mit diesem Dogma, mit alle sollen versorgt werden.
Dafür ist das auch da. Und jetzt kommen sie mit so Zahlen von,
naja wir wollen jetzt von 98% auf 99% kommen.
Und da stellt man sich dann irgendwie so eine komplette Deutschlandkarte vor,
wo überall irgendwie Netz ist. Das stimmt natürlich nicht, weil ja nur von den
Haushalten die Rede ist.
Also wir reden jetzt wirklich nur von so einem besiedelten Gebiet,
bis wir halt irgendwo, wo jetzt nicht Haushalte sind oder nicht die Haushalte,
die nicht mehr diese 98% reingepasst haben,
dann stehst du da und dann kommt halt so ein beklopptes Argument wie,
naja, da wohnen hier nur 350 Leute, das lohnt sich ja nicht.
Dass da vielleicht auch mal ein paar andere Leute, die da nicht wohnen,
da auch hinwollen und vielleicht da nicht hinwollen jetzt, weil man da eben kein Netz hat.
Auf so eine Idee kommt offensichtlich auch überhaupt niemand.
Und es ist einfach nur noch lächerlich und dann irgendwie auch noch so ein Puppanzer
draus zu machen, das Ganze irgendwie zu feiern wie so ein Schützenfest.
Meine Güte, das ist einfach ein besseres Symbol für die Unmöglichkeit,
dieses Netzausbaus gibt es irgendwie gar nicht.
Und das ist halt tatsächlich das Problem von öffentlicher Infrastruktur.
Dass natürlich musst du die auch da hinbauen, wo sie sich mal nicht lohnt.
Klar, kannst du ja nicht einfach einstellen, so wie mit der Deutschen Bahn,
als die dann privatisiert wurde, wo sie dann irgendwann den Leuten gesagt haben,
wir machen das jetzt hier wieder weg mit der Bahn, hier hält die jetzt nicht mehr. Ja.
Lasst euch wieder einfallen, was ihr damit macht. Das geht so nicht.
Ja, das ist auch irgendwie, keiner würde jetzt auch diskutieren über,
naja, also wir haben ja jetzt die Wasserversorgung für 98 Prozent der Haushalte
haben wir ja auch sichergestellt.
Und die Stromversorgung, da sind wir jetzt nächstes Jahr wahrscheinlich auch schon bei 99 Prozent.
Ja, aber die restlichen lohnt sich nicht. Da wohnen ja nur sehr wenige.
Die können ja ins Nachbardorf fahren, wenn sie mal Strom Die tragen den Strom
in Eimern irgendwie aus dem Nachbardorf über den Berg Ja,
das ist wirklich eine Schande.
In anderen Ländern geht es ja auch. In skandinavischen Ländern wie Schweden,
die haben nicht nur seit Ewigkeiten Glasfaser-Internet, wo vor 10 Jahren 100
Mbit und heutzutage in Gigabit rausfallen für 20, 30 Euro im Monat für alle
symmetrisch hoch und runter,
sondern da gibt es auch LTE am letzten Kaff und noch nicht mal Kaff,
sondern wo nur Elche sind, wo noch nicht mal 300 Leute sind.
Jeder Elch hat da mehr Netz als hier die Bürger.
Die haben das halt einfach als politische Priorität erkannt, dass man das möchte.
Und wenn diese politische Feststellung da ist, dann kann man da umgehen, wie man das realisiert.
Aber hier sagt man halt immer, das muss der Markt schon irgendwie richten.
Und die Telekom sträubt sich halt.
Das ist der Elchtest für die Bundesregierung.
Bevor hier nicht jeder mehr Netz hat als jeder Elch in Schweden,
gibt es einfach keine Ruhe.
Elchtest für die Bundesregierung, das ist gut.
Elchtest und bin ich schon drin. Das heißt 90s Revival.
Das versteht doch wahrscheinlich wieder gar keiner, was der Elchtest ist, oder?
Das kann man in die Sendungsnotizen schreiben.
Der Elchtest war der Diesel-Skandal der 90er.
Da wird jedes Auto gebaut, wird in der Kurve umgefallen.
Die A-Klasse, genau. Der Elchtest ist, wenn das Auto quasi einem Elch auszuweichen
hat und dann ist das Ding irgendwie umgekippt und dann haben sie mit Software nachgerüstet.
Bei einem Test in Schweden.
Ursprünglich hieß der Test in Schweden Kindertest.
So, ich würde sagen, genau.
Wir schicken jetzt mal, die deutsche Mobilfunknetz, das ist ja offenbar eh nur aus Provisorien.
Wir fahren jetzt mal hier so einen Mobilfunkanhänger von der Telekom nach Schweden
zum Echtest, wenn der dann übersteht.
Aber einen habe ich noch.
Die haben aber wahrscheinlich auch bessere Antennen. Das wird dann das Argument
von der Bundesregierung sein.
Du hast noch einen.
Die haben ja da einen ganzen Bus von Journalisten, an netzpolitischen Journalisten
vom Verkehrsministerium in Berlin-Mitte
in dieses, ich hab's schon wieder vergessen, wie das Dorf heißt,
Glesengörne, gefahren, um die PR-Aktion des großen Ministers zu begleiten.
Es wurde wohl WLAN am Bus versprochen, aber das hat auch nicht funktioniert.
Das kommt erst 2040. Nur in Bayern. Genau.
Also eine einzige PR-Aktion. Das ist ja auch Sommerloch seit diesem Sommerpause, seit dieser Woche.
Und da hat der Minister halt gedacht, der macht sich mal einen schönen Fototermin.
Ey, ist das zum heulen. Sommerloch. Wenn das ein Sommerloch wäre,
wäre gut, aber deshalb im Winter auch. Okay,
jetzt haben wir sie, glaube ich. Jetzt haben wir alle Schenkelklöpfe.
Liebe, liebe Dorfjugend-Klesengörne, solange ihr Internet habt,
macht euch schlau, wie ihr diese Funkmasten da verteidigen könnt.
Ich würde dem Braten nicht trauen.
Hört noch Buchnetzpolitik.
Solange ihr könnt.
Also es ist ja offenbar auch ein Telekom-Mast nur, ne?
Das heißt, ich bin natürlich auch mal gespannt, ob dann da in Klissen-Görne,
was da jetzt die Kunden, obwohl die werden ja keine Kunden sein.
Oder meinst du, wobei, wenn die aus dem Dorf rausgehen, vielleicht haben die
sich auch einfach an der Funkloch-Grenze so eine schöne Schein-Bushaltestelle
hingebaut, wo man, dass man, wenn es regnet, nicht nass wird beim Telefonieren.
Oder so alte Telefonzählen könnte man da hinstellen, weißt du?
Davon gibt es so richtig viele.
Die gelben sind leider inzwischen abverkauft. Es gibt nur noch diese neueren 90er Dinger.
Magenta Dinger.
Ja.
Naja. Also Klesengörde.
Gratulation.
Und alle anderen, die immer noch kein Netz haben, die können ja jetzt nach Gleisenkörne fahren.
Ja, da können sie sich halt auch so ein Volksfest organisieren.
Oder ladet einfach erstmal die Japaner ein, über euch zu berichten.
Das scheint ja zu funktionieren. Vielleicht sollte man einfach mal die Schweden einladen.
Das schwedische Fernsehen, so über die Diaspora in Deutschland.
So eine schöne Dokumentation, die packt man dann in Arte rein.
Ich stell mir so gerade vor, diese japanische Dokumentation,
so ein düsteres Bild, so ein Brandenburger Hand. Und dann holen die irgendwie
das Telefon raus und dann staunen die Ureinwohner.
Aber es funktioniert eh nicht.
Kennst du diese lustigen Shows, wie die in Japan so aufgezogen sind?
Takeshis Castle?
Ja, das auch. Aber auch wenn so Dinge in Europa berichtet wird und so.
Weil das ist sehr, sehr lustig.
Also die werden auch immer so komischen Storys zusammengebaut.
Also ich kann mir das lebhaft vorstellen.
Ja, das ist ungefähr so wie jetzt irgendwie, wie heißen denn so diese Disney-Dokus
über den Urwald, wo dann irgendwie der Erzähler oder so David Attenborough, amazing creatures,
die Bürger von Gleeson-Görne schaffen es mehrere Wochen, ohne eine Datenverbindung
auszuholen. They have arranged themselves.
They can last.
Okay.
Nur die Elche kommt da nicht vorbei, weil sie selbst mit ihren Großantennen keinen Empfang haben.
Vielleicht findet ja ein Leser oder eine Leserin diesen japanischen Fernsehbeitrag
und postet den in den Kommentaren. Ich würde das gerne machen.
Oh Gott, diese Sendung wird nicht mehr normal.
Wir müssen aber jetzt wieder zu den schlechten Nachrichten kommen.
Die müssen noch beschäftigt.
Der Gedanke, dass man so ein Funkelch hat, die mit WLAN-Hotspots durch die Städte
laufen, um die Grundversorgung herzustellen.
Du bist doch der Erfinder der Datenklo-Installationen beim Camp.
Jetzt kommt der Datenelch.
Der Datenelch trägt aus seinen Schultern Proviant für drei Wochen.
Mit Storch drauf. Oh Gott.
Das ist dann auch okay für die Wavys in der Region.
Da fällt das nicht so auf.
Hier muss irgendwo Datenelch sein.
Okay, hat mir so ein anderes Thema.
Es ist fürchterlich, es ist wirklich ganz schlimm.
Komm, lass uns mal irgendwas dystopisches raussuchen.
Achso, jetzt auch bald in Klesengörne? Staatstrojan. Es war nicht alles gut im Internet.
André, das war dein Einsatz.
Linus, willst du mir nicht eine schlaue Frage stellen?
Ich habe, du hast mir ja schon, also ich habe jetzt gehört, gehört,
dass die Bundesregierung brüstete sich ja seit längerer Zeit damit,
sie sei nun in der Lage, Staatstrojaner einzusetzen.
Die erste Meldung, die wir hatten, war glaube ich, dass das BKA sagte,
wir haben jetzt ein Windows- Trojaner für Skype oder sowas.
Das war irgendwie so das Ausmaß des Schaffens, was das BKA in Eigenentwicklung
da von Stack Overflow zusammen kopiert, pastiert hatte.
Und, ähm, dann war aber natürlich auch, ich glaube, das war auch wieder eine
Informationsbefreiung von dir,
schon davor, klar, dass sie seit längerer Zeit im Gespräch sind mit dem Unternehmen
Gamma, Finnfischer Elgamam hieß, glaube ich.
Elamann.
Elamann hieß quasi die Briefkastenfirma zur Ausübung dieses Vertrages,
zur Erfüllung dieses Vertrages und jetzt,
nachdem jetzt die Meldung war, wir haben einen funktionierenden Smartphone Trojaner,
kam da jetzt auch ein bisschen Licht ins Dunkel oder auch nicht,
weil die Frage gestellt wurde,
ey, wo habt ihr den denn her?
Und dazu hast du jetzt die Antwort, wie immer aus den nicht öffentlichen Quellen
befreien können. Oder etwa nicht?
Ja, das Thema Trojaner bestätigt uns ja schon ein paar Jahre.
Der CCC hatte ja damals, wann war das, 2011 oder 2012, so ein Trojaner auf einer
hessischen Firma Digitask aufgemacht.
Wie hat der das, der BKA-Typ im Innenausschuss hat das gemeint und uns ist die
Software damals aufgeplatzt.
Wir müssen vielleicht, weil das auch tatsächlich, wie du es gerade sagst,
so ein bisschen eine Zeit her ist.
Also damals war die Geschichte der Staatstrojaner, weil es ging los mit der
Idee, dass sie einen haben wollen.
Dann war glaube ich damals noch…,
Vom Bundesverfassungsgericht für den CCC Andreas Bruck, wenn ich mich nicht täusche.
Ergebnis dieser Verhandlungen damals war, dass ein neues Grundrecht festgeschrieben wurde.
Grundrecht auf Vertraulichkeit und Integrität informationstechnischer Systeme.
Das Computergrundrecht. Das Computergrundrecht.
Und zwar weil digitale Geräte heutzutage so viele Informationen über uns speichern
und über lange Zeit und alle möglichen Sensoren haben und private Daten und
Kommunikation und Notizbuch und Logins für andere Dienste und so,
Also dass das eigentlich ein ausgelagertes Gehirn ist und quasi noch ein intensiverer
Grundrechtseingriff ist,
in diese Geräte einzudringen, als denn schon das Mithirn irgendwie in Privaträumen,
also im Wohnzimmer oder so, als so ein Lauschangriff ist.
Also das ist quasi eins der intensivsten Eingriffe in die Privatsphäre,
die der deutsche Staat so kennt.
Deswegen hat das oberste Verfassungsgericht eben ein neues Grundrecht geschaffen,
dass der Staat die Integrität und Vertraulichkeit dieser Systeme zu schützen hat.
Und zwar nicht nur passiv, sondern auch aktiv. Und nur in ganz,
ganz, ganz begrenzten Ausnahmefällen könnte es legitim sein,
in diesen besonders geschützten Bereich einzudringen.
Und zwar ging das damals um eine Befugnis für das Bundeskriminalamt und zwar
nur bei internationalen Terrorismus und nur zur Prävention von internationalen Terrorismus. muss.
Damit haben wir ein paar Tage gelebt, ein paar Jahre, aber.
Landeskriminalämter, manche und Zollbehörden haben das auch genutzt und noch
ein bisschen anders eingesetzt. Daher kam ja auch die Software,
die der CCC untersucht hat.
Aber gerade letztes Jahr als letzte Aktion der GroKo vor der Wahl wurde der
Staatstrainer einmal massiv ausgeweitet und zwar nicht nur gegen,
nicht nur für das Bundeskriminalamt, sondern für alle Ermittlungsbehörden.
Nicht nur zur Prävention, sondern auch auch zur Strafverfolgung und nicht nur
für Terrorismus, sondern für sämtliche schweren Straftaten, die im Katalog vom
100a sind, wo irgendwie alle möglichen Dinge drinstehen, bis hin zu Geldwäsche,
missbräuchliche Verleitung oder Verleitung zur missbräuchlichen Asylantragstellung,
und Haufen so eine Delikte, die jetzt nicht als der Staat, die Funktion oder
das gesellschaftliche Zusammenleben fallen auseinander oder gar irgendwie mordkörperliche
Unversehrtheit oder sowas sind, mit dem das ja oft begründet wird.
Das, die Sache im letzten Jahr war das, wo ich dann auch als Sachverständiger in dem Bundestag war.
Das war das, wo wir so, naja, mal wieder auf die...
Aufs Zahnfleisch gedrückt wurden mit einer Einladung in den Ausschuss wenige
Tage vorher, wo es halt irgendwie sehr anstrengend war.
Habe ich drüber berichtet, mit Sicherheit hier im Jahresrückblick des CCC und
so weiter, findet ihr nochmal in den Shownotes.
Ich glaube, was du nicht mit drin hattest, war zwischendurch noch das BKA-Gesetz
und die Klage gegen das BKA-Gesetz.
Da ging es auch um Staatstrojaner, wurde Wurde auch in Karlsruhe verhandelt,
da war Konstanz für den CCC wieder mal die Sachverständige und auch darüber
haben wir damals mit ihr gesprochen. Also die Geschichte ist eine lange.
Ja, das hat ja angefangen mit Polizeigesetz NRW und jetzt auch BKA-Gesetz und
das wurde jetzt nochmal auf dem BKA-Gesetz nochmal umgeschaffelt und so.
Und das ist jetzt auf verschiedene Landespolizeigesetzen, siehe Hessentrojane
und so ist das Thema. Also es gibt da diverse Gesetzesinitiativen,
wer wann wo Staatstrojaner einsetzen darf.
Und die schönste Aktion war dann eben CCC-Aktion.
Oktober 2011, wo uns dann eben ein solcher Staatstrojaner in die Finger gekommen war,
der dann in Ruhe analysiert wurde von Mitgliedern des Chaos Computer Clubs und
also im Reverse Engineering dann eben verschiedene nicht legale Funktionalitäten gefunden wurden,
die zu dem sofortigen Stopp des Einsatzes geführt hatten und vor allem halt
auf mehreren Ebenen nachgewiesen haben,
dass diese Software nicht ihren rechtlichen Rahmenbedingungen entsprach.
Genau, es gibt ja einen kleinen und einen großen Staatstrojaner.
Also der kleine ist die sogenannte Quellentelekommunikationsüberwachung,
wo man in so ein Gerät eindringend infiziert und dann angeblich nur die laufende
Kommunikation überwacht.
Das wird immer so beschrieben wie, das ist ja nichts weiter als eine normale
Telefonüberwachung, nur halt jetzt, um über die Crypto-Messenger rumzukommen.
Ist natürlich trotzdem anders, weil man muss erstmal in das System einbrechen,
statt sich einfach nur eine Kommunikation ausleiten zu lassen und da passiert
ja schon der größte Eingriff und es war eben in der Software,
die damals eingesetzt wurde,
eben nicht so, dass der sich nur auf die laufende Kommunikation beschränkt hat.
Das geht ja auch technisch gar nicht wirklich.
Und da kam dann eben raus, der hat Screenshots gemacht die ganze Zeit,
der hat Entwürfe, Notizen, nicht abgeschickte Mails und so, das ist alles mit
den Akten gelandet, irgendwie hunderte oder tausende Screenshots,
die dann dort abgedruckt wurden.
Also dann kam noch dazu, dass die Infrastruktur so rotten war,
dass man das sofort übernehmen konnte und den Trojaner auch noch irgendwelche
Dinge nachladen konnte, wo man die Funktionen dann wieder erweitern konnte und so.
Also das ist wie der BKA-Typ, der für die Trojaner zuständig ist,
gemeint hat, aufgeplatzt.
Und dann war auch ziemlich schnell klar, dass die Software nicht mehr eingesetzt werden darf.
Dann hatten die Behörden, BKA und andere Polizeibehörden das Problem,
ja, jetzt haben wir die eine Software, die wir die ganze Zeit genutzt haben,
aber die dürfen wir nicht mehr nutzen, was machen wir denn jetzt?
Dann kamen sie auf die glorreiche Idee, ja, dann programmieren wir halt einen eigenen.
Den haben sie programmiert, das ist die sogenannte Remote Communication Interception
Software, das ist der kleine Staatstrojaner vom BKA,
der konnte in Version 1, haben sie irgendwie drei Jahre dran programmiert oder
so, konnte der eben Skype auf Windows abhören, das war nicht wirklich viel,
also haben sie nur eine zweite Version hinterhergeschrieben.
Vor allem inzwischen hat Microsoft doch Skype gekauft und einen Masterkey reingedingst.
Das mit dem Masterkey weiß ich nicht genau, können wir gerne ergänzen,
aber Skype war noch nie so wirklich das Problem.
Geht da auch eher um andere, die wollten ja jetzt auch, es geht ja vor allem
um WhatsApp und so ein Zeug.
Haben sie in Version 2 auch noch entwickelt, das BKA die jetzt wohl auch Messenger
und wohl auch mobile Geräte, also Android iOS und sowas kann,
die ist auch seit diesem Jahr seit irgendwann in den letzten Monaten nicht nur fertig,
sondern auch überprüft und zum Einsatz freigegeben die können aber nur Quellen
TKÜ sie dürfen ja auch die Online-Durchsuchung Das ist der große Trojaner,
der eben nach der Infektion von einem Gerät nicht nur die Kommunikation auslesen kann,
sondern alle Dinge, die da drauf gespeichert sind.
Also wie eine komplette Hausdurchsuchung, eine Online-Durchsuchung auf den Geräten.
Und dort ist dann wirklich alles drin betroffen, wie bei einer Durchsuchung,
nur eben, dass es von einem ausgelagerten Gehirn ist.
Also mal gucken, was allein so auf dem Smartphone oder einem Rechner alles für
jahrelange alte Daten gespeichert sind und so.
Wenn sich die Polizei schon bei Printausdrucken nicht auf die vom aktuellen
Jahr begrenzt, da wo sie im Durchsuchungsbefehl stehen.
Aber diese Online-Durchsuchungstrojaner haben sie noch nicht programmiert,
die haben jetzt angefangen auch dafür eine Software zu programmieren.
Bisher haben sie schon 6 Millionen Euro ausgegeben, um die zwei Ärzteversionen
mit irgendwie 30 Leuten im BKA zu entwickeln.
Das geht jetzt auch so halb in die Zitis über, soll es zumindest.
Ist auch noch ein bisschen shady, wie die zusammenarbeiten, aber bis der Eigenentwickler
der Trojaner soweit war, haben sie gesagt, naja, wir können jetzt,
Digitask ist weg, aber unsere bedauert noch ein Stück, brauchen wir trotzdem
noch einen Trojaner, also haben sie sich auf dem Markt umgeguckt,
was gibt es da so, haben bei Google eingegeben Staatstrojaner und haben Finnfischer gefunden,
über den wir auch schon öfters mal berichtet haben.
Also Finnfischer wird als komplettes Portfolio des Hackens bezeichnet,
das ist eine RAT, also eine Trojaner Software,
die sehr advanced ist,
die sehr weit entwickelt ist, die ziemlich weit vorne in der technischen Expertise
ist, weswegen sie auf der ganzen Welt auch beliebt ist von sogenannten Sicherheitsbehörden.
Also die wurde gefunden in Ägypten, Bahrain, Äthiopien, Uganda und jetzt auch Türkei und so.
Also nicht gerade bei den Top Ten der Menschenrechts- und Pressefreiheitsranglisten weltweit.
Dort natürlich auch nicht nur gegen die Schwerstkriminellen und Terroristen
eingesetzt, sondern gegen Journalisten und Aktivisten, aber die werden da teilweise
in diesen Ländern auch einfach als Terroristen bezeichnet.
Und diese Firma, die keine Skrupel hat, in solche Länder zu verkaufen,
hat eben auch an das Bundeskriminalamt ihre Software geliefert.
War ein kleines Problem, weil dann hat das BKA geprüft, ob die Software auch
wirklich nur das kann, was sie darf.
Die wollten ja den Fehler nicht wiederholen, den sie mit Digitask hatten.
Und dann hieß es aber, nee, die kann viel mehr.
Schicken wir hier zurück, dass sie nur das darf, was in unserer Anforderungsliste steht.
Und dann haben sie nach ein paar Monaten eine neue Version geschickt.
Und die konnte aber immer noch mehr.
Und das ganze Spiel haben sie dreimal gespielt. und Fynn Fischer so oft überarbeitet
und eingedampft, dass sie dann im Endeffekt erst zur Freigabe freigegeben wurde,
jetzt im Januar oder so, also nachdem die BKA-Software selber fertig programmiert wurde.
Ähm, das ist jetzt nicht so PR-mäßig super für die Bundesregierung und die Firma.
Deswegen gab es jetzt vor ein paar Wochen Anhörungen im Innenausschuss, wo das Parlament,
die Legislative kontrollierte ja die Regierung, die Exekutive,
wo die sich mal wieder erzählen lassen wollten, was ist denn der Sachstand,
worum geht es denn beim Trojaner, was macht ihr denn so, wie oft setzt ihr das
ein, was kostet das und so weiter und so fort, von wem kauft ihr das?
Und dann hieß es auf einmal von der Regierung, oh, also von wem wir unsere Software
kaufen, das können wir überhaupt nicht sagen, denn wenn das bekannt wird,
dann kündigen die Firmen ihre Verträge.
Die wollen nicht, dass bekannt wird, dass sie mit der Bundesregierung zusammenarbeiten.
Das ist krass, das war für uns ziemlich überraschend, denn ich meine,
die originale Meldung, dass sie Fynn Fischer kaufen, kam zwar auch aus einem
geleakten Dokument bei uns, aber wir haben ja dann auch den Vertrag freigeklagt
und so, den die mit Fynn Fischer hatten.
Also das war jetzt kein Staatsgeheimnis, sie ist ja jetzt irgendwie so geheim,
dass sie das nicht mal geheim oder streng geheim einstufen und irgendwie eine
Geheimschutzstelle versenken,
sondern das wird dem Parlament gar nicht gesagt, weil angeblich der Bestand
der Bundesrepublik dann gleich gefährdet wäre, wenn diese Firmen bekannt werden
und dann ihre Trojaner nicht mehr ans BKA liefern könnten.
Das ist schon eine krasse Nummer, wo eben auch Abgeordnete ziemlich pisst sind
und gemeint, also so eine Informationspolitik geht gar nicht,
das Parlament kontrolliert eben die Regierung und so einfach wollen sie die dann nicht rauslassen.
Die FDP und die Grünen drohen auch mit Klage, die Prüfung mit Klage,
wenn die Bundesregierung diese Antworten nicht rausrückt.
Aber die Antwort, die irgendwie vom BKA und vom Innenministerium ist,
ja haben sie doch Verständnis, es gibt da nicht so viele Anbieter auf dem Markt,
es gibt da nur eine Handvoll und wenn wir die verprellen, dann haben wir gar keine mehr.
Bitte, bitte vertraut uns doch einfach. Einfach. Doch, das wirklich sagen die genau so.
Also habe ja die Protokolle von der Innenausschusssitzung veröffentlicht.
Bitte vertraut uns doch.
Wenn wir keinen Trojaner haben, dann ist Sodom und Gomorra. Und um einen zu
haben, dürfen wir euch halt nicht sagen, von wem.
Die sagen auch, im Übrigen könnt ihr ja selber googeln, so viele Firmen gibt es nicht.
Das sagen die den Abgeordneten auch so. Ja, dann guckt doch einfach mal,
was es da draußen so gibt.
Und wahrscheinlich sind wir in Gesprächen mit denen, ob wir das nutzen könnten oder nicht.
Ich halte das für eine Schutzbehauptung, um nicht zu sagen eine Lüge,
dass diese Unternehmen sich irgendwie, dass die darunter leiden würden,
dass sie mit Deutschland Geschäfte machen.
Wenn du irgendwie dieses Ding nach in alle irgendwie zweifelhaften Regime dieser Erde exportierst,
dann wirst du, wenn die Bundesrepublik Deutschland mit ihrem verbleibenden guten
Ruf dein Kunde ist, darunter nicht eintreten.
Nicht mehr negative Konsequenzen haben, als wenn, als du vorher hattest,
als du das Zeug in die Türkei und irgendwie in den Nahen Osten verkauft hast.
Ich glaube vielmehr, dass die Bundesregierung
sich hier schämt für ihre Zulieferer und deren Kundenstamm.
Dass nämlich die Bundesregierung nicht sagen möchte, ja hier von führenden Diktatoren
empfohlen haben wir uns für folgendes Produkt aus dem Hause Gamma entschieden,
mit dem ja auch schon irgendwie in der Türkei die Oppositionellen so gut unter
Kontrolle gebracht wurden.
Rhein, Ägypten, Rhein, Ägypten.
Wahnsinn eigentlich. Und noch dazu,
ich meine die Bundesregierung verheimlicht nicht die Tätigkeiten von irgendwie
so traditionsreichen Familienunternehmen wie Krauss-Maffei Wegmann,
Rheinmetall, Heckler & Koch, die irgendwie, weiß nicht wie viel Prozent der
gewaltsamen Tode auf diesem Planeten verantworten durch ihre Produkte.
Da sagt auch keiner, versteht doch bitte, wenn wir euch sagen,
woher wir diese Leopard 2 haben, dann bauen die den nicht mehr.
Ja, wahrscheinlich nicht.
Wahrscheinlich werden die sagen, oh ne, wir haben das ja immer nur geheim gemacht
und jetzt sind wir verbrannt. Jetzt wisst ihr, dass wir heimlich hier diese
Panzer für euch gebaut haben. Das ist doch totaler Stuss.
Das sehe ich ähnlich. Ich glaube auch, nicht nur die Bundesregierung hat Angst
vor der Öffentlichkeit, wenn schwarz auf weiß nachgewiesen ist,
dass sie Produkte kaufen, die auch irgendwie Schurkenstaaten auf der ganzen Welt einsetzen.
Sondern ich glaube auch, dass die Firmen Angst vor der schlechten Presse haben,
die die kritische Medienöffentlichkeit in Deutschland, gerade die Netzöffentlichkeit so hat.
Und wir haben hier nun mal relativ viel Bums in der öffentlichen Debatte,
in anderen Ländern nicht so.
Und wie gesagt, das Digitask, nach dem CCC-Ding sind die pleite gegangen.
Die wurden jetzt die Reste von Rode und Schwarz gekauft, die übrigens auch höchstwahrscheinlich,
also von Epoch, so eine Leipziger Bude für die Packet-Inspection.
Ich glaube, ich habe die Theorie, die wollen einen neuen Staatstrojaner entwickeln
oder den alten weiterentwickeln.
Ganz rein zufällig ist von der CITES, der Hackerbehörde, irgendwie jetzt der
Abteilungsleiter für die Trojaner-Abteilung steht fest und der kommt von Rode und Schwarz.
Können wir uns auch nochmal genauer angucken. Und ich glaube einfach,
die Firmen haben bisschen Schiss vor dieser kritischen Öffentlichkeit,
vor diesem Auge der Öffentlichkeit an die Öffentlichkeit, an die wir sie zerren werden.
Weil wir hier halt nachhaken und nachgucken und so.
Und dann eben, wenn der CCC irgendwann so ein Sample von Finn Fischer oder was
auch immer in die Hand guckt, ich meine, dann würde sich die Hände reiben danach.
Wir freuen uns darauf, wenn wir das haben. Ich glaube, davor haben sie Schiss.
Und das ist ein Erfolg für CCC und uns und die ganze Szene und so.
Aber die Begründung geht trotzdem nicht, selbst wenn sie es haben.
Ich meine, das Parlament, das irgendwie wir wählen, das kontrolliert die Regierung
und die Regierung kann sich nicht so rausreden von mir, sagen euch das nicht,
weil die Firmen sonst irgendwie böse werden und keine Geschäfte mehr mit uns machen.
Konstantin von Notz hat dann so flapsig gesagt, wegen Reichtum geschlossen. Ja genau.
Und das ist halt ein Problem der Zulieferungsqualität dieses Unternehmens und
der politischen Entscheidungen der Bundesrepublik, solche Technologien zum Einsatz zu bringen.
Und nicht ein Problem des Namens dieses Unternehmens. Ja, und das denke ich
auch, also selbst wenn all das wahr wäre,
ja, und man eben sagt, oh, wenn das, wenn rauskommt, was die für eine Scheiße
machen, das Unternehmen pleite geht,
ja, so be it, so ist das eben, wenn du Scheiße baust als Unternehmen.
Das kannst du ja nicht, also ich glaube auch nicht, dass sich daran etwas ändern würde.
Ja, wenn jemand dieses Sample analysiert und feststellt, dass es irgendwie,
was weiß ich, nicht dem Stand der Technik oder dem Stand der Grundrechte entsprechend,
dann werden da halt Köpfe rollen und das ist völlig unerheblich dafür,
ob öffentlich bekannt ist, wer den Schrott verbrochen hat oder nicht.
Ich glaube, das ist ein ziemlicher Erfolg für uns.
Das ist natürlich lästig, dass sowohl die Firmen als auch die Bundesregierung
mauern, aber ich glaube schon, die haben Schiss vor der Öffentlichkeit.
Aber mittlerweile ist wirklich jedes Dokument und jede Sitzung,
in der es um den Trojaner geht, standardmäßig eingestuft.
Also da passiert überhaupt nichts mehr öffentlich, das ist sofort irgendwie
Stempel und wenn es nur NFD ist, was irgendwie die niedrigste Stufe ist,
aber das heißt zumindest, das darf theoretisch nicht öffentlich werden und das
muss dann irgendwie erst über einen Leak einen Weg zu uns finden, ehe das bekannt wird.
Die wollen doch nicht mal sagen, wie viele laufende Strafverfahren mit oder
auch Gefahrenabwehrverfahren mit Staatstrojaner einsetzen sie haben,
weil das könnte ja irgendwie Rückschlüsse auf die Art der Verfahren und auf
die Trojaner geben und so. Das ist auch so eine obskure Ausrede.
Die Regierung und die Firmen mauern beide aus Angst vor der Öffentlichkeit.
Ich glaube, deswegen sollten wir mehr Öffentlichkeit darauf schaffen.
Nur für den Dienstgebrauch.
Ja, dann reden wir da auch weiterhin drüber.
Ja, man sieht ja in den USA, was passiert, wenn die Politik irgendwann keine Scham mehr spielt.
Scham ist ein wichtiger Aspekt in der Politik.
Ja, wobei sogar die sind nicht completely untouched. Also, dass sie jetzt irgendwie
auch noch aus allen Restaurants rausgeworfen werden und auf der Straße angespuckt
werden, das hebt nicht unbedingt die Arbeitsmoral im Weißen Haus.
Das werden die bestimmt auch irgendwann noch verbieten.
Darauf kann man sitzen, ja.
Wo ich ja Schwierigkeiten habe, eine starke Meinung zuzuhaben oder eine definitive Meinung.
Bundesgerichtshof.
Bundesgerichtshof, ja. Es handelt sich um einen Rechtsstreit,
der glaube ich inzwischen seit fünf Jahren diese Familie beschäftigt.
Es geht um eine Familie, die eine Tochter verloren hat durch einen Todesfall im Schienenbereich.
Und nun ist es wohl so,
dass die Familie gesagt hat, naja, die Umstände dieses Todes sind uns irgendwie
nicht klar und wir erhoffen uns Erkenntnisaufklärung,
Seelenruhe in irgendeiner Form, wenn wir Zugriff auf das Facebook-Konto unserer
verstorbenen Tochter bekommen.
Und dann haben die gesagt, Facebook, gib uns den bitte. Und dann hat Facebook
gesagt, nee, hier gilt das Fernmeldegeheimnis der Kommunikationspartner eurer Tochter,
die ja hier in eine Kommunikation getreten sind, in der Annahme,
dass sie unter dem Fernmeldegeheimnis stattfindet.
Dieses Fernmeldegeheimnis gilt für diese Person weiterhin und deswegen verweigern
wir die, Das Zugänglichmachen der Daten.
Das ging durch mehrere Instanzen. Das Berliner Kammergericht hatte diese Sperre
unter Verweis auf das Fernmeldegeheimnis noch bestätigt.
Und nun war dieser Fall eben vor dem Bundesgerichtshof.
Facebook hat eben argumentiert, hier sind andere Personen, deren Persönlichkeits-
und Fernmeldegeheimnisse werden verletzt.
Der BGH hat aber dann argumentiert, naja, auch Briefe und Tagebücher würden
ja an die Erben übergehen und deswegen besteht kein Grund,
digitale Inhalte anders zu behandeln.
Die Tochter hatte mit Facebook einen Nutzungsvertrag geschlossen und die Eltern
sind eben als Erben in diesen Vertrag eingetreten.
Das heißt, nach Auffassung dieses Urteiles ist also davon aktueller Rechtsstand,
dass ihr im Todesfall euren Facebook-Account mitvererbt.
Und damit eben das Recht der Erben einhergeht, dort auch Einsicht zu erhalten.
Ich finde das immer noch nicht wirklich optimal, weil mich jetzt zum Beispiel,
also die Eltern verstoßen ja gegen die AGBs, wenn sie diesen Account wirklich
betreiben, weil der Account muss ja unter dem richtigen eigenen Namen betrieben werden.
Also geht es darum, dass der betrieben wird oder geht es nur darum,
dass er in dem Zustand, in dem er jetzt gerade ist, so einsehbar ist?
In diesem Fall geht es um die Einsehbarkeit der Daten dieses Accounts.
Also noch zum Hintergrund, Facebook hatte nach dem Tod dieses Mädchens,
kann man es nennen, die war glaube ich 16, den Account in den Gedenkmodus geschaltet.
Das ist so ein Feature, das sie haben für Accounts von Leuten,
die gestorben sind. und die Eltern hatten aber, ich glaube aus Aschsprache mit
ihrer Tochter, das Passwort, die Logindaten.
Und sie kamen nur mit den Logindaten nicht mehr rein, weil der Account eben
nicht mehr aktiv war, sondern im Gedenkzustand war.
Und die Eltern wollten jetzt aber nochmal in die Facebook-Messages nachgucken,
weil das Mädchen von der Uhr an überfahren wurde und die wollten irgendwie Gewissheit,
ob das irgendwie vielleicht auch ein Suizid hätte gewesen sein können oder so.
Und Facebook hat gemeint, nee, weil der im Gedenkzustand ist,
lassen wir euch da nicht ran, sonst hättet ihr euch da einloggen können.
Weiß jemand von euch, warum war der überhaupt, also wie ist der in diesen Gedenkzustand gekommen?
Das ist eine gute Frage, die sich mehreren Leuten stellt und das mir nicht so ganz klar ist.
Normalerweise muss man eine Sterbeurkunde hinschicken oder so.
Aber vielleicht auch wegen, ich weiß es nicht ganz genau, nee.
Das ist eine gute, zumindest mir nicht geklärte Frage.
Ja, weil ich meine, da müssen natürlich auch schon bestimmte Hürden übernommen
werden, sonst könntest du ja hier jeden einfach mal sterben lassen per E-Mail
und das kann ja nicht sein, auch so eine Sterbeurkunde ist dann auch schnell mal gefälscht.
Also der Prozess würde mich mal sehr interessieren und den müssten ja dann eigentlich
die Eltern auch angestoßen haben.
Also das ist das, was mich jetzt so ein bisschen verwirrt.
Das ist mir auch nicht ganz klar. Jedenfalls, ich meine, ich habe kein Facebook-Account,
aber soweit ich das weiß,
kann man in diesem Gedenkzustand dann diesen Account nicht mehr betreiben und
nichts Neues mehr posten, sondern höchstens irgendwie noch ein letztes Mal das
Profilbild ändern oder so und eben in ein paar der jüngeren Nachrichten nachlesen.
Und das war das, was die Eltern wollten.
Nicht jetzt im Namen der Tochter diesen Account weiter füttern.
Also haben sie sich ihn unter Umständen selbst weggenommen, aber der Zeitpunkt,
ich meine, dann müssten sie ja dann gleich am Anfang auch schon dieses Interesse gehabt haben.
Also man weiß es nicht, in dem Zustand.
Man hat ja auch erst mal ein paar Wochen mit Bewältigung und anderen Verfahrensgraben,
Formalitäten zu tun und so, bis sie irgendwann auf diesen Account kommen,
war es dann soweit, vielleicht hat irgendwie genug von den Freunden das gemeldet
oder so, bei Facebook, keine Ahnung, wie das passiert ist.
Also in dieser Zustand-Gedenkmodus heißt in Englisch memorialized und es gibt
eine Facebook-Hilfeseite.
My account is memorialized.
If you believe we've mistakenly memorialized your account, please let us know.
Also note that if you're not the owner of this account and the actual owner
has passed away, we can't provide login information or reactivate this account
under any circumstances.
Also das ist spezifisch offenbar diese Seite, über die hier diskutiert wurde,
beziehungsweise du hast die deutsche Variante davon.
Ja, also und man findet auch immer wieder Leute, die im Internet sich darüber
beklagen, dass sie entgegen ihrer Realitätsauffassung in diesen Gedenkzustand
versetzt wurden und sich freuen würden,
da wieder rauszukommen. Und für die ist eben diese Seite.
Da kann man sich dann eine E-Mail senden lassen und muss ein Foto hochladen, wo man noch lebt.
Mit einem Fisch über dem Kopf.
Genau, und der BGH hat jetzt die Antwort, wie ich finde, relativ überlegt gegeben,
auch wenn, natürlich, das ist ein echt komplizierter Fall, aber er sagt,
der Datenschutz, also der Schutz von Briefpost- und Fernmeldegeheimnis mit den
Kommunikationspartnern dieses Mädchens muss in diesem Fall hinter dem Anrecht
der Eltern auf den Account hinterherstehen, Denn,
und hier wird es ziemlich interessant,
die Kommunikationspartner haben ja...
Nicht nur mit dieser natürlichen Person kommuniziert, sondern mit diesem Facebook-Account.
Und der Facebook-Account ist meistens identisch mit dieser Person,
aber auch zu Lebzeiten kann eben sein, dass das Passwort abhandengekommen ist
und dann quasi andere Leute auch diese Nachrichten lesen.
Also man hat kein, wie steht es hier, es besteht aber kein schutzwürdiges Vertrauen
darauf, dass nur der Kontoinhaber und nicht Dritte von dem Kontoinhalt Kenntnis erlangen.
Und das heißt jetzt nicht generell, dass das eine Freigabe ist,
sämtliche Nachrichten auch an Externe rauszugeben, aber eben im Fall der Nachlassverwalter
der Erben, der Eltern dieser Tochter führt das dazu,
dass eben Erben, die auch Briefe und Tagebucheinträge lesen dürfen,
mit dieser Begründung auch die Facebook-Nachrichten lesen dürfen.
Also da bin ich ja überhaupt nicht für.
Wenn Facebook hat, würde jetzt entgegnen, dass sie dafür die Möglichkeit haben,
dass du in deinem Account selbst bestimmen kannst, was passiert, wenn du tot bist.
Haben sie.
Du kannst das wohl festlegen in verschiedenen Stufen. Da kommt niemand rein
oder das wird gelöscht oder irgend sowas.
Ich kenne mich damit nicht aus. Ich habe nicht nur kein Facebook Account,
sondern ich würde auch nicht mal anfangen wollen zu versuchen,
diese ganzen Optionen und Einstellungen in diesem Facebook verstehen zu wollen.
Wie ich höre, sind die sehr verzweigt. Aber es gibt da wohl irgendwo in Formular
B23 in Untergruppe auch Häkchen, was passiert,
wenn du stirbst und Facebook das mitbekommt und wer dann welche Dinge von dir bekommt oder so.
Und ich nehme an, nach diesem Urteil wird das Facebook jetzt nochmal genauer machen.
Das Problem ist nur, dass 99% aller Menschen sich nicht damit beschäftigen und
das vorher nie so wirklich einrichten, sondern man ist halt irgendwann,
stirbt man ehemals erwartet und dafür plant und dann dafür sind halt die Fälle
von was passiert, wenn jemand nicht dafür vorgesorgt hat.
Vor allem, also ich denke,
es wäre auf jeden Fall notwendig, dass solche dann doch sehr fundamentalen Fragen
nicht durch BGH-Urteile geklärt werden, sondern …,
Dass wir hier eine ernsthafte gesetzliche Regelung zu haben,
wo einfach drinsteht, was weiß ich, wenn du, was passiert im Erbrecht mit Daten.
Das könnte sein, dass man Telemediendienste verpflichtet, dafür Lösungen anzubieten,
dass man das irgendwie vorher sagt.
Es gibt natürlich auch andere Fragen, die das digitale Erbe betreffen,
zum Beispiel wie E-Books oder MP3s, die man gekauft hat, die an irgendwelche
Accounts gebunden sind,
wo ja dann die Betreiber natürlich auch eigentlich die Ansicht vertreten,
nee, nix, das wird nicht vererbt, der Account ist jetzt zu, die Person gibt
es nicht mehr und fertig, die nimmt ihre E-Books mit ins Grab.
Während man natürlich auch sagen könnte, nee, wieso, hier, das Kapital bei Amazon,
das haben wir bezahlt und dieser, das möchten wir jetzt lesen,
das ist ja immerhin die Ausgabe von meinem Vater. Vater.
Keine Ahnung. Da sind Sachen zu klären und das ist irgendwie so ein philosophisches
Thema, was irgendwie dann auch leider solche tragischen Fälle braucht,
bis es mal da wirklich eben ein gesteigertes Interesse von Personen dran gibt.
Ich persönlich habe schon, glaube ich, ein Konzept dafür, welche Daten ich mit
ins Grab nehmen möchte und welche nicht.
Und es ist natürlich wichtig, dafür im Moment eben privat vorzusorgen.
Das ist ja bei allen anderen Vorsorgen auch so.
Ich will da eine Trojaner-Sammlung haben.
Ach, die kannst du doch dann auch nur noch ins Museum tun. Außerdem,
die habe ich ja verteilt.
Ins Linus-Talman-Musik.
Hast du das Konzept in deinem Kopf oder hast du das irgendwo notiert?
Das Konzept manifestiert sich in der Form, wer welche Kryptokies kriegt.
Okay.
Der klickt hier auch einmal am Tag auf die Totmann-Taste. Und wenn er das...
Ganz normal.
Was passiert, wenn du im Urlaub bist und er hier nicht mehr reinkommt?
Also kleiner Nachtrag, ich habe jetzt hier etwas hilflos in diesem Hilfe-Bereich
von Facebook rumgeklickt, wenn ich das richtig verstehe,
man kann wohl einen sogenannten Nachlasskontakt bestimmen, selbst wenn man das
gemacht hat, dann ist sozusagen im eigenen Todesfall klar, wer diesen,
Account dann quasi im Gedenkzustand kontrollieren kann, mit den den entsprechenden
Einschränkungen, die du schon genannt hast, also Profilbild,
irgendwie neue Freundschaftsanfragen, Handhaben etc., so kleinere Sachen,
aber eben nicht mehr viel und schon gar nichts ändern.
Und die Frage, wie kann denn dieser Gedenkzustand überhaupt erfolgen?
Da ist ja von die Rede halt so Familien oder Freunde und es gibt so ein Formular,
da trägst du Namen, Datum ein und optional eine Sterbeurkunde.
Optional.
Also,
das riecht so ein bisschen danach, als ob ja irgendwie auch schnell mal Leute
digital versterben könnten, die vielleicht im echten Leben noch völlig herumlaufen.
Unklar, schwieriges Thema. Rein,
moralisch kann ich das hier alles nachvollziehen irgendwie, auch was die Familie da so fühlt.
Das ist einfach eine große Lehre, glaube ich, die man da,
hat, wenn man irgendwie so ein Kind verliert, vor allem in so einem jungen Alter
und natürlich macht man sich halt Gedanken darüber, warum ist das jetzt passiert
und will an jede Information kommen.
Also an der Stelle sind dann halt die,
gibt es halt verschiedene Ansprüche quasi an die entstandenen Kommunikationen
und Rechte müssen hier miteinander abgeglichen werden.
Genau das ist der Punkt, warum ich argumentieren würde, es wäre besser,
dass wirklich jetzt, dass das gesetzlich klar ist, wo jeder Mensch weiß,
so und so ist die Rechtslage, das
wird passieren, damit solche Fragen halt hoffentlich auch nicht aufkommen.
Zumal das dann auch bei allen Plattformen einheitlich ist, weil jetzt betrifft
dieses Urteil Facebook und vielleicht ein paar andere dieses ähnlich Verhalten.
Ja, bei Twitter kann ich jetzt keinen Nachlasskontakt einstellen.
Gibt es da einen Gedenkzustand?
Wär mir auch neu.
Nee, gibt's nicht, weil regelmäßig dann auch alte Accounts von Verstorbenen aufgemacht werden.
Zum Beispiel Schiermachers Account ist auch schon wieder länger her.
Hat Frank Schiermacher auf einmal irgendwie Spam scheiße getwittert,
weil den halt irgendeiner aufgemacht hatte.
I'm back from the dead sozusagen. Ja, da musste man dann mal bei Twitter Bescheid
sagen und dann haben die das,
auch wieder gelöscht und den Account irgendwie so den Ja, also ich meine,
klingt alles ganz lustig, aber so tendenziell wird natürlich das,
was wir so digital vorrätig haben auf all diesen Plattformen auch immer signifikanter werden.
Ich stelle mir gerade so vor, meine Eltern sind gestorben und was hast du geerbt? Zwei Terabyte.
Also man muss tatsächlich mal, es geht ja auch um die Geräte.
Also primär bei mir geht es um Geräte, weil ich irgendwie keine nennenswerten Cloud-Präsenzen habe.
Es geht auch um Zugriff auf Verträge, Policen, Unterlagen.
Systeme, die irgendwie im Betrieb gehalten werden müssen, die von anderen Leuten
weiter administriert werden sollen genau Deine Buchhaltung, wer bekommt eine Buchhaltung?
Ja, ich meine, es sind alles so Sachen, wo es halt auf jeden Fall auch,
wo Leute davon, wo anderer Leute Leben potenziell in Gefahr gerät,
dass auf einmal dieser Zugriff auf diese Daten nicht mehr möglich ist,
also klar kann man kritisieren, dass das vorher schon von einer anderen Person
Aber so sind die Dinge eben, es entwickelt sich immer so und das ist sicherlich
ein Thema für die nächsten Jahre,
mal darüber nachzudenken, wie man solche Prozesse auf allen Ebenen machen kann.
Also allein, dass es vielleicht auch mal so eine Art strukturierten Speicher
gibt mit, was habe ich eigentlich.
Also dass quasi so mein digitales Eigentum sich auch in irgendeiner Form vererbbar
überhaupt niederschreiben lässt.
Wenn ich jetzt hier irgendwie ablebig werde, dann wisst ihr ja noch nicht mal,
wo hat denn der Tim überhaupt einen Account gehabt, wo liegen denn die Bitcoins
rum, die vererbt werden sollen etc.
Pp. Das ist schwierig und ich glaube, wenn ich mich selber mal abtelefonieren
müsste und mal durch meine ganzen Accounts durchgehen müsste,
um mal alles einzusammeln, was macht mich eigentlich aus und was würde ich davon jetzt.
An meine Kinder weiterreichen oder wem auch immer oder eben auch an die Öffentlichkeit,
da hätte ich doch einiges mit zu tun.
Ja, macht euch da mal Gedanken drüber, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer.
Genau, da würden mich auch mal eure Gedanken sehr zu interessieren.
Da gibt es sicherlich viele Aspekte, die wir jetzt auch noch nicht mal angekriegt haben.
Wir kommen langsam in den Bereich der Kurzmeldungen.
Uuuuh, die populären Ecken dieses Podcasts.
Ein Thema, was wir hier auch immer mal wieder behandelt haben, war diese Idee,
durch die Durchsuchung von Mobilgeräten von Geflüchteten, Auskunft über deren Identität zu erlangen.
Also Argumentation war oder ist, die geflüchtete Person kommt im,
wie heißen die Zentren, Auffangzentrum an der Grenze an und möchte,
wie heißen die denn nochmal?
Du meinst jetzt die neuen Transitzentren.
Transitzentren.
Bisher kommen sie ja da ja nicht an.
In Zukunft. Die geflüchtete Person wird im Transitzentrum gefangen gehalten
und muss Auskunft über ihre Identität geben, hat jetzt aber dummerweise im Rahmen
der Seenotrettung leider den Pass verloren.
Ja, und jetzt ist die Frage, wie kann sie denn jetzt eben nachweisen,
wer sie ist und woher sie kommt,
weil davon abhängig der durchaus ist, die Entscheidung über ihre Aufnahmemöglichkeit
einen Antrag auf Asyl zu stellen oder sonstiges. ist. So.
Bisher wurde das dann gelöst darüber, dass sie mit quasi ortskundigen Menschen
und Menschen, die kundig in der Region sind, Unterhaltungen geführt haben.
Das heißt, da sagst du dann, ich komme aus dem und dem Land und dann kam halt
jemand, der auch aus diesem Land ist, der deinen Akzent beurteilen konnte,
der dir dann vielleicht ein paar Fragen dazu gestellt hat, wie das Leben sich dort gestaltet,
um die Geschichte, die diese Person erzählt, irgendwie zu Das halte ich für
ein durchaus sinnvolles Verfahren, das natürlich die Herausforderung hat,
dass es nicht besonders gut skaliert
und zu starken Verzögerungen in der Behandlung dieser Fälle führt.
Lösungsvorschlag von, ich weiß gar nicht, ob öffentlich ist,
wer diese Idee ursprünglich hatte, auf jeden Fall nicht direkt die Bundesregierung,
war, nehmt doch die Mobilgeräte von den Leuten und lest die Daten aus,
die sich darauf befinden.
Im Sinne von, was sind da für Fotos, die Fotos werden in der Regel mit Metadaten
versehen, in welcher Sprache finden sich Nachrichten,
was hat dieses Mobiltelefon alles an Metadaten gespeichert, die irgendwie über
die Aufenthaltsorte dieser Person Auskunft geben.
Und das findet sich jetzt auch im Einsatz.
Es gibt viele verschiedene Architekturen, wie man so etwas bauen könnte.
Es gibt aber natürlich einfach Software
zur Datenauslese, die primär von Strafverfolgungsbehörden verwendet wird.
Das heißt, man konnte das jetzt auf die Privatsphäre respektierende oder weniger
respektierende Art machen und vor allem konnte man sich auch überlegen,
ist das jetzt eine Standardmaßnahme,
die man andauernd macht oder eine, die man eben nur selten zum Einsatz bringt.
Die Linksfraktion hat da mal eine kleine Anfrage zugestellt und primäres Ergebnis ist,
der Verdacht, dass bei der Angabe
der Identität im großen Umfang Betrug vorkommt, bestätigt sich nicht.
Nicht. Es ist irgendwie in der Phase vom September 2017 bis Mai 2018,
ich glaube September 2017 ist dieses System so gefühlt in den Produktivbetrieb gegangen,
zwischen September und Mai knapp 15.000 Betroffene, die keine Papiere vorlegen
konnten und bei denen wurden dann eben Mobiltelefone, Pads, Laptops oder was
auch immer sie hatten ausgelesen.
Der Zugriff soll nur dann stattfinden, wenn es keine milderen Mittel zur Feststellung
der Identität mehr gibt, wie zum Beispiel ein Gespräch. In ca.
5000 Fällen, also ca. ein Drittel dieser Fälle, wurden also dann Daten ausgelesen
und die Daten haben die Angaben gestützt.
Zwei Drittel ließen keinen relevanten Informationsgehalt erkennen hinsichtlich
der Identität und nur in 100 Fällen von eben 15.000 widersprachen die Daten dem,
was die Personen bei der Befragung gesagt hatten.
In dem Zeitraum wurde über ca.
230.000 Asylanträge entschieden. Nicht angenommen, lieber AfDler.
Über 230.000 Anträge entschieden. Das heißt, ein großer Teil davon kam einfach mit Papieren.
Bei 15.000 hatten keine Papiere und von den 15.000 wurden 100 falschen Angaben überführt.
Das System hat irgendwie sowas wie 4,8 Millionen Euro gekostet.
Ähm, entscheidender Punkt hier ist, dass es natürlich ein Dammbruch war,
dass Menschen ihre Identität darüber ausweisen,
dass sie eben sich einmal komplett gläsern machen,
was ihr digitales Leben angeht.
Und im Artikel von Leo Thür, Alexandra Fanta und Chris Köwer auf Netzpolitik.org
steht eben auch wichtig, vom gläsernen Geflüchteten zum gläsernen Bürger ist
es nur ein kurzer Schritt.
Insbesondere, wenn man sich deren Realitäten anschaut.
Also ich halte das nach wie vor für ein ethisch durchaus sehr fragwürdiges Instrument.
Ja, wir hatten ja vorhin schon, wie diese modernen Geräte, die wir rumtragen,
unsere ausgelagerten Gehirne sind und teilweise mehr Informationen über uns
gespeichert haben, als uns selber teilweise bewusst ist.
Und jetzt werden Leute eben gezwungen, sich komplett nackig zu machen dafür,
obwohl in den allermeisten Fällen die ganz normale BAMF-Anhörung und Befragung
mit Dolmetschern und regionalen Experten immer noch das bessere,
mildere und auch genauere Mittel ist. Ich meine, die Leute werden ja eh angehört.
Aber prophylaktisch werden ja eben von 15.000 Leuten schon mal die Handys ausgelesen,
weil man könnte es ja in 100 Fällen auch brauchen.
Und das ist eben eine Grundrechtsverletzung, denn nicht umsonst haben wir gerade
über das Recht auf die Gewährleistung der Vertraulichkeit
und Integrität informationsverarbeitender Systeme gesprochen.
Soviel zum Zwischenstand dazu. Eine Nachricht, die heute eigentlich kaum noch
jemanden interessiert, ja, so merkt man, das läuft so unter ferner Liefen,
ne Tim, jetzt hast du zu weit gescrollt.
Mindestens seit 2000 hat der BND mehrere Filialen und Tochtergesellschaften
deutscher Unternehmen im europäischen Ausland ausspioniert.
Wir erinnern uns, der BND ist der Auslandsgeheimdienst, der darf gegen alle
spionieren, die nicht Deutschland sind.
Darunter war jetzt eine spanische Filiale eines Weiterbildungsbetriebs für die Automobilbranche,
die österreichische Filiale eines Hamburger Schleifmittelherstellers,
die niederländische Firma eines
Spezialtransportunternehmens und ein Chemieunternehmen aus Österreich,
das seit 2001 einer hundertprozentigen Tochter des deutschen Bayer-Konzerns gehört.
Ja, das ist die Funktionsträger-Theorie. Die durften ja auch Günther Oettinger
abhören, wenn er in seiner Funktion als EU-Kommissar auf Englisch mit seiner
.eu E-Mail-Adresse geschrieben hat.
Bis es dann irgendwann rauskam, sie einen Aufriss gekriegt haben und das ändern
mussten. Aber das war ja lange Zeit deren Gedankenmodell.
Warum haben die nichts gegen den unternommen?
Das ist nicht deren Aufgabe. Ich meine, wenn er Englisch redet,
unternimmt er, naja, genug.
Angesprochen auf dieses Thema teilt der BND mit zu operativen Aspekten nachrichtendienstlicher
Arbeit, nimmt die Bundesregierung grundsätzlich nur gegenüber den zuständigen
geheimtagenden Gremien des Deutschen Bundestages Stellung.
Die Antwort kann ich auswendig, die kriege ich auch jedes Mal genauso,
diesen selben Satz immer, bei jeder Anfrage an den BND.
Der BND berichtet an die Bundesregierung, die Bundesregierung berichtet in den
geheimtagenden Gremien gegenüber,
also es ist doch eigentlich nur ein geheimtagendes Gremium, oder?
Es gibt vor allem das PKGR, es gibt aber auch das Vertrauensgremium,
was manche Haushaltsdinge entscheidet und so.
Ah, okay.
Aber ja, vor allem das PKGR.
Wir bleiben in Österreich, auch so eine Meldung, die in Deutschland weniger
Aufsehen erregt hat als in Österreich.
Der deutsche Geheimdienst hat zwischen 1999 und 2006 zentrale Einrichtungen
in Österreich überwacht in der Telekommunikation, Ministerien,
Polizeibehörden, Universitäten, Botschaften und Unternehmen,
ebenso wie Waffenhändler und Terrorverdächtige.
Mehr als 2000 E-Mail-Konten, Telefonfax und Handynummern befinden sich unter den Selektoren.
Gegenüber dem österreichischen Standard wurde von mehreren Quellen bestätigt,
dass diese Selektoren, die da vorgelegt wurden,
authentisch sind und auch hier natürlich wieder ja, da sind die schon sieben
Jahre überwachen die Ministerien in Österreich und wen haben sie jetzt als Kanzler?
So, hat auch wieder nichts gebracht. Ich frage mich so, wo bleibt hier mal der Wirksamkeitsbeweis?
Es ist natürlich eine Katastrophe für das das deutsch-österreichische Verhältnis.
Ausspähen unter Freunden.
Das geht gar nicht.
Überhaupt nicht.
Geht überhaupt nicht. Und liebe österreichischen Hörerinnen und Hörer,
wir finden das nicht gut.
Und wir entschuldigen uns für unseren BND. Wir versuchen alles Mögliche gegen den zu unternehmen.
Aber auch unsere Zeit ist begrenzt.
Denn wir müssen demonstrieren. Wir mussten demonstrieren. Wir haben ja aufgerufen.
Nee, haben wir nicht. Da haben wir noch einen für offensack bekommen.
Ich glaube, wir haben es in der Sendung davor aber getan.
Demonstrationen gegen das Polizeigesetz in NRW. Ich glaube, wir haben in der
Sendung vor der letzten dazu aufgerufen.
Ich glaube, wir haben das sogar zweimal erwähnt.
Ja, wir haben deswegen auch 18.000 Teilnehmerinnen und Teilnehmer in der Düsseldorfer
Innenstadt und bis vor den Landtags sind sie marschiert,
um zu demonstrieren gegen die Einführung einer Quellentelekommunikationsüberwachung,
von einer Gefährderhaft, wo man bis zu einem Monat in Gewahrsam kommen kann,
weil man als Gefährder identifiziert wird.
Gefährder, wie gesagt, keinerlei Beweise.
Und dann kommst du mal einen Monat in Haft zur Sicherheit.
Diese Polizeigesetznummer, die wird jetzt in jedem einzelnen Bundesland kommen.
Also wenn ihr nicht in Bayern oder Nordrhein-Westfalen lebt,
sondern zum Beispiel in Brandenburg, dann könnt ihr euch freuen,
das wird auch dorthin kommen.
Das wird jetzt mehr oder weniger in jedes Bundesland kommen.
Was haben wir jetzt gerade aktuell für eine Regierungskonstellation in Brandenburg?
Brandenburg weiß ich nicht.
Rot-Rot. SPD hat aber das Innenministerium und die wollen das mit Trojanern und allem Pipapo.
Die Linken finden das nicht so gut, aber das ist wie in Hessen,
wo manche Grüne das auch nicht ganz so gut finden,
aber die Union treibt die so sehr und die Grünen sind so klein und die Fraktionsspitze
hält sich dann an den Fraktionszwang und die gemeinsame Regierungs-whatever-blub.
Also die brauchen einen ordentlichen Gegenwind von ihrer Basis und der Öffentlichkeit,
damit eben auch die Linke in Brandenburg und die Grünen in Hessen sich dagegen
stimmen können. Obwohl Hessen ist glaube ich durch, das ist beschlossen.
Auch ein PAG schon.
Oder redest du von der Trojaner-Geschichte?
In Hessen war es halt die gesamte Hessen-Trojaner-Nummer.
Ja gut, aber jetzt rede ich ja spezifisch von dieser, also was ich an diesen
Polizeigesetzen wirklich so furchtbar finde, ist, dass es einfach mal so dermaßen
offensichtlich gegen meiner Auffassung nach die Verfassung,
verstößt, weil es einfach nicht sein kann, dass man einfach ohne Beweise Leute weg schließt.
Die eigentliche Begründung für die ganzen ganzen Polizeigesetz-Novellen ist
ja nicht nur die Datenschutz-Grundverordnung, sondern auch die in dem Zuge passierte,
Richtlinie, wie wir eben die Behördendaten zu verarbeiten haben und man könnte
das einfach in einer Formalität anpassen, so wie das Bundesdatenschutzgesetz
auch angepasst wurde an die Datenschutz-Grundverordnung.
Also, dass alle Bundesländer ran müssen, das ist eigentlich vorgegeben.
Aber eben in fast allen Bundesländern sagen wir, ah, wir fassen unser Polizeigesetz
an, dann machen wir hier doch mal den Wunschkatalog auf und schieben da alles
rein, was wir schon immer mal haben wollten oder uns vorstellen konnten.
Ja, und das ist halt genau das. Also ich meine, ich kann mir nicht vorstellen,
dass das in Berlin irgendeine Chance hat.
Da würde ich mit definitiven Aussagen in der Politik würde ich mich zurückhalten.
Prognosen sind schwierig, besonders wenn sie die Zukunft betreffen.
Ja, das ist richtig, aber ich glaube, das Widerstandspotenzial in Berlin dürfte da signifikant sein.
Es gibt auch zwei Arten von Berlin. Es gibt ja auch Gedanken zu dem sogenannten
Muster-Polizeigesetz, um auf Bundesebene quasi eine vereinheitlichte gesetzliche
Lösung für Landespolizeigesetze zu machen, im Aufgabenbereich von Horst Seehofer.
Alter, also das wird irgendwann auch noch auf uns zukommen.
Aber im Land Berlin ist es zumindest nicht so präsierend wie eben gerade in
NRW oder auch Bayern gewesen.
Linus, wir können André nicht so oft einladen. Ich kann hier meine Rolle als
Optimismusbeauftragter nicht uneingeschränkt durchführen, wenn er hier mit seinen
Realitätseinblicken kommt.
Realität ist schuld, nicht ich.
Ja, ja, ich weiß. Aber du hast das hier auf den Tisch gelegt,
also wirst du dafür auch verhaftet.
Tim.
Ja.
Du hast doch bestimmt gesehen, dass jetzt die Stadt vollgestellt wurde mit diesen Leihfahrrädern.
In allen Farben, die der Regenbogen so bietet, außer lila.
Aber ich würde jetzt eigentlich gerne die Gelegenheit nutzen,
dass du von dem fundamental großartigen ersten Leihfahrrad-Hack des CCC berichtest.
Doch, des CCC. Der war so geil. Das Umfeld. Das waren wir nicht.
Kennt hier jemand jemand?
Das wurde in der Datenschleuder publiziert irgendwie eben.
Und naja, auf jeden Fall, man muss ja mal sagen, da war ja die Bahn interessanterweise
wirklich sehr visionär unterwegs und hat schon vor vielen, vielen Jahren,
vielleicht könnt ihr das mal nachschlagen, wann das jetzt eigentlich war.
Ich schaue gerade schon.
Gab es die, wie hießen die Dinger jetzt nochmal?
Call-A-Bike. Hacker-Bike.
Call-A-Bike. Call-A-Bike-Fahrräder mit eigener Elektronik, mit GPS-Ortung, Netzverbindung etc.
Mit so einem kleinen Bordcomputer, mit einem fernauslösbaren Schloss auf die
Straße gebracht und man konnte das halt mit dem Mobiltelefon freischalten,
indem man da irgendwo angerufen hat, sich eine Nummer hat durchgeben lassen,
die in dieses Bike eingegeben hat und dann war das Bike aufgeschlossen.
Und die Nummer rotierte natürlich, damit man sich die nicht merkt,
wenn man immer dieses Fahrrad nimmt und dann wurde das berechnet,
ich glaube so grob 50 Cent für jetzt eine normale Fahrt oder so.
Ich weiß es gar nicht mehr. Also es war auf jeden Fall ein sehr interessanter
Dienst und in gewisser Hinsicht auch total, wann war das?
2004, Hack a Bike war die Aktion.
Vier, alter Schwede. Also an der Stelle auch gleich mal Lob an das Unternehmen,
was das ursprünglich mal realisiert hat.
Die waren schon ganz gut und das wäre auch fast hackerfest gewesen.
Allerdings haben sie einen Fehler gemacht, nee zwei Fehler gemacht.
Der erste Fehler war, dass sie nicht bei allen Fahrrädern ein bestimmtes Bit gesetzt haben,
so ein Lock-Bit, was das einfache neue Flächen des E-Proms oder des entsprechenden
Speichers auf der Elektronik des Gerätes hätten verhindern können oder zumindest
den Prozess hätten deutlich erschweren können.
Und der zweite Fehler war gar nicht von diesem Unternehmen, sondern von der Bahn,
die halt breitbeinig in der Hauszeitschrift glaube ich damals über Callabike
berichtet haben und dann auch irgendjemand zitiert haben mit dem Satz,
die wären ja auch nicht hackbar.
Das war leider, also den Spruch hätte man sich wahrscheinlich sparen können,
aber ihr könnt euch vorstellen, was dann passiert ist.
Menschen sind dann mal dieser Technik ein wenig auf die Spur gekommen,
da wurden dann Analysen durchgeführt, auch auf einem professionellen Level.
Du hast es ja damals glaube ich noch nicht mitbekommen Linus,
aber ich kann dir sagen das hätte dir viel Freude bereitet dieser Prozess den zu begleiten,
also da ist nach allen Maßgaben der Hackerkunst vorgegangen worden also da wurde
wirklich das große Besteck rausgeholt und die Dinger wurden einfach seziert
mit dem Ergebnis, dass halt hier Lücken gefunden wurden und am Ende.
Fahrräder sich durch ein,
auffälliges Blinken auf der Straße verraten haben, dass man hier nicht einen
Code erst abrufen muss, sondern dass hier quasi eine universelle PIN galt und
dementsprechend waren dann viele dieser Fahrräder fahrscheinlos.
Ein fahrscheinloser persönlicher Nahverkehr wurde dort implementiert.
Das ist alles ganz lustig. Natürlich kann man jetzt über die Moralität dieser
Maßnahme auch streiten und das ist auch gestritten worden,
weil hier ein paar Leute auch so ein bisschen mit den Pferden durchgegangen
sind, weil nun ist es ja Hacker-Ehre, dass man so etwas durchführt und dann
dokumentiert und aufzeigt und öffentlich macht.
Und hier gucke mal, wir haben das irgendwie geschafft und macht doch mal eure Dinger dicht.
Aber die pure Nützlichkeit dieser Fahrräder hat sie dann doch dazu verleitet,
hier die Zahlen in anderen Bereichen nach oben zu treiben.
Ich glaube am Ende war sowas wie 10 oder 20 Prozent der Flotte wurde sozusagen dynamisch befreit.
Und Leute haben sich hier eine eigene Infrastruktur gemacht und noch schlimmer,
Leute konnten dann natürlich irgendwie auch das Maul nie halten.
Und irgendwann hatte sich das dann in Berlin so weit rumgesprochen,
dass das natürlich dann auch den Betreibern auffiel und dann gab es Diskussionen.
Das war ja auch vor allem das Problem, dass die Leute dann mit irgendwie raus
aufs Land gefahren sind zu Partys.
Die waren dann auf Partys angeschlossen in Berlin und so weiter.
Weil die Schlösser brauchten, weil die wussten, dass das Fahrrad sich durch sein Blinken verrät.
Also es war, also öffentlichkeitstechnisch finde ich, ist die Nummer nicht gut
gelaufen. Technisch war es ein Meisterwerk.
Okay, aber lass mal so als Ausblick.
Die Backdoor erlaubt, das Hackebike mit einem von uns festgelegten Ausleihcode einfach zu öffnen.
Wenn man das Hackebike dann wieder abgibt, ist es ganz normal wieder ausleihbar.
Es hatte einfach einen festprogrammierten Standardcode und durch das Blinken
der LED machte es sich sogar bemerkbar.
Also die Dinger haben immer geblinkt, wenn sie verfügbar waren.
Die blinken immer so regelmäßig so bing, bing, bing.
Grüne LED, ne?
Und wenn das achte Blinken, jedes achte Blinken aussetzte, wusstest du,
dieses Fahrrad war auch anders.
Und das gibt's jetzt wieder.
Jetzt stehen auf jeden Fall auf einmal mal eine ganze Menge von diesen Dingern rum.
Interessant, dass es jetzt 30 Jahre dauert, bis hier ein Boom einsetzt,
aber jetzt geht's ja gerade richtig los.
Also die Deutsche Bahn hat das ja einfach nur verkackt mit diesem Call-A-Bike.
Sie hatten, das war wunderschön, du hattest natürlich die unschönen Phänomene von irgendwelchen ähm,
Gründungen der Schöpfung, die diese Fahrräder dann halt beschädigen,
wegwerfen und also quasi, ich meine, ist eine Sache dann ein schönes Kunstwerk
aus einem Fahrradstapel zu machen, ist ein anderes, das Fahrrad irgendwie halt zu beschädigen.
Das war, Vandalismus war da ein Problem, die landeten regelmäßig in irgendwelchen
Müllcontainern vom Bau und dann waren sie halt auf die Gnade der Bauarbeiter
angewiesen, die Fahrräder wieder rauszuholen und insgesamt fand ich das eigentlich großartig.
Die Flotte war ein bisschen zu klein, hätte noch größer sein können.
Man musste mitunter relativ weit zu einem Fahrrad latschen.
Und dann haben sie es nach ein paar Jahren umgeschaltet auf diese Stationsfahrräder.
Ganz schlechte Idee.
Was der Tod wiederum war des Bike-Meetings, des Bike-Rentals,
weil in Berlin gab es vielleicht irgendwie gefühlt sechs,
vielleicht auch nur fünf solcher Stationen.
Es funktioniert in Städten wie New York oder Paris mit diesen Stationen,
weil die dafür sorgen, dass an jedem fucking U-Bahnhof so eine Station ist.
Und das ist wiederum genau das, das ist akzeptabel für Menschen,
die diese Systeme nutzen wollen, weil die eben mit den U-Bahn-Stationen ohnehin vertraut sind.
Das heißt, die wissen, wo sie hinfahren müssen und unterwegs gab es dann auch
nochmal irgendwie so Stationen. Also ich bin in Paris regelmäßig mit diesen
Dingern unterwegs und kann da nicht klagen, weil wirklich an jeder Ecke so eine Ausleihstation ist.
Das ist wirklich, das ist in Ordnung. In Deutschland wurde es halt mit diesen
Stationswesen verkackt.
Und die standen da auch gerade Level 2, indem sie das A massiv noch weiter ausbauen
und B auch überall noch stromt.
Ja, also die haben funktionierende Infrastruktur, diese Länder.
Deutschland hat halt keine funktionierende Infrastruktur. Das haben wir nicht.
Mobilfunk.
Ich warte ja noch, dass irgendwie O-Bike oder so irgendwie mit Pauken und Trompeten,
eine Station eröffnet in Klessengörne.
Kannst damit zum See fahren. Ja, in Berlin ist jetzt in den letzten Jahren,
Ich glaube, im letzten Jahr sieben waren das, glaube ich.
Sieben?
Es gibt Mobike, O-Bike, Ofo, Lime E, Lidl.
Das ist das alte Kolle-Bike?
Genau, Nextbike.
Und jetzt habe ich wahrscheinlich noch eins vergessen. Es gibt wahrscheinlich
sogar acht. Heise hat sechs.
Ja, aber so die Kategorie ...
Und all diese ganzen Anbieter versuchen sich halt jetzt hier den Markt unter die Finger zu reißen.
In anderen Städten funktioniert es teilweise schon sehr gut.
Also insbesondere in China ist das Fahrrad da wiederentdeckt worden und chinesische
Unternehmen sind da auch sehr weit vorne.
Mobike, wobei ich jetzt von ihren Fahrrädern nicht so begeistert bin,
die sind mir einfach zu klein.
Die Mowbike-Fahrräder haben den Sattel zu klein und wenn es kalt ist,
rutscht die Sattelstange runter und dann fährst du dir mit den Dingern die Knie kaputt.
Die haben Antrieb über eine Kardanwelle. Also ich sag mal, für eine längere Tour sind die nicht gut.
Aber ich muss trotzdem sagen, dass ich immer mal wieder mich in einer Situation
wiederfinde, häufig, wenn der Tag mit Regeln beginnt und ich gezwungen bin,
die Dienste, das ist ein großes Wort, der Berliner Verkehrsbetriebe in Anspruch
zu nehmen und dann nicht erwischt werde, dass ich die in Anspruch genommen habe.
Und auf dem Rückweg sagt, ach jetzt scheint die Sonne und man entfernt sich
dann halt vom Ort des Geschehens mit so einem Leihrad,
das ist Mietfahrrad, Leiden ist ja nicht verfallt, dann ist das schon ganz in Ordnung.
Und Heise hat einen sehr schönen Test gemacht von allen Anbietern und haben
dann eben die geratet und haben dann auch wirklich mal gesagt,
bei denen schleift regelmäßig die Bremse.
Viele von den Rädern haben übrigens Hartgummi-Reifen, was dann auch natürlich
den Komfort ein bisschen schmälert. und jetzt waren die alle oder mehrere dieser
Anbieter von kuriosen Schwachstellen gesegnet.
Und zwar war dieses Ofo, war das glaube ich, wo du jetzt hoffentlich brichst
du dich durcheinander, Ofo haben diese komplett gelben Fahrräder gehabt.
Und es begab sich dann, dass du merktest, dass insbesondere sehr junge Menschen.
Mit diesen Ofo-Fahrrädern rumfuhren und vor allem, die fielen dadurch auf, dass sie so ziellos.
Rumfuhren und die Dinge, an denen sie sich im Park liegen hatten und so und
da gab es, die hatten direkt zwei wunderbare Schwachstellen.
Du konntest nämlich den Anmeldeprozess, beim Anmeldeprozess durch mehrmaliges
Drücken auf dem Display umgehen, dass du eine Kreditkarte angeben musstest,
bevor du deine erste die erste kostenlose Fahrt in Anspruch nehmen konntest.
Und wenn du dann die erste kostenlose Fahrt ohne Angabe eines Zahlungsmittels
oder einer E-Mail-Adresse in Anspruch nehmen konntest, dann konntest du diese
Fahrt einfach nicht beenden,
sodass diese Dinger überall unabgeschlossen in der Gegend rumstanden,
was super praktisch war, weil dann musstest du es ja nicht bezahlen.
Weil du hast einfach deine erste kostenlose Fahrt nie beendet und so wurden
halt eins nach dem anderen von diesen Rädern aufgemacht und wurden dann eben auch, sag ich mal,
ein bisschen zeitsouveräner genutzt, wenn du jetzt irgendwie gegen die 30-Minuten-Schranke
bis zur nächsten Bezahlung anfahren musst als Jugendlicher,
dann hast du da einfach ein anderes Fahrgefühl auch,
als wenn du weißt, das Fahrrad kann ich nicht so lange fahren,
wie ich will, weil es ist offen.
Andere hatten nicht so gute Befestigungen dieser Schließsysteme,
Sodass du da mit einem kleinen Schraubenzieher vom Konrad oder einem langen
Ast dieses Schloss dann auch entfernen konntest.
Insofern, diese standen halt bei mir in der Gegend, wo relativ viele von den
Fahrrädern rumstanden, die waren
ruckzuck auch wieder wie damals alle mit Abus-Schlössern ausgestattet.
Weil das Blöde ist natürlich, wenn dir jemand sein Fahrrad wieder wegnimmt,
du brauchst ja ein Schloss weil das Schloss ist ja in dem Moment auf und so
ist dann jetzt auch einer dieser Anbieter nämlich O-Bike in die.
Insolvenz gegangen sind nicht mehr erreichbar die Fahrräder von denen stehen
in mehreren Metropolen dieser Welt und in Berlin rum und da gibt es jetzt eine
wunderschöne eine Anleitung, wie man die upcyclen kann.
Denn O-Bike ist so pleite, dass sie noch nicht einmal mehr die ursprüngliche
Sign-Up-Fee von 75 Dollar, die sie irgendwie in Singapur abgenommen haben,
ihren Kunden zurückzahlen können, geschweige denn ihren Schrott jetzt aus dieser
Stadt wieder rausholen können.
Und jetzt stehen überall diese O-Bikes rum.
Und da gibt es eine wunderschöne Webseite mit dem mit der URL,
librebike.info wo erklärt wird, wie man diese Fahrräder mithilfe eines Schraubenziehers,
eines Lötkolbens oder eines Akkuschraubers sowie eines Holz-Chopsticks,
die essen Stäbchen, befreien kann und aus diesen Leih- und Mieträdern wieder
echtes Bikesharing machen kann.
Glaubst du, es gibt Ärger?
Von wem denn?
Von O-Bike?
Ich denke, die sind dicht.
Müsste schon O-Bike sich beschweren, aber dann sollen die erst mal ihre Kaution
den Leuten wieder zahlen.
Das haben sie in Deutschland glaube ich nicht abgenommen, das war nur in anderen Ländern.
Libre-Bike hat den Unterschied zu den bisherigen Aktionen, Tim hat erzählt,
dass man beim CCC einen Code wissen musste, um die zu entsperren.
Der war jetzt nicht so schwer zu erraten.
Und ja, das musste man aber trotzdem erstmal wissen und man musste da auf den Blinken achten.
LibreBike versteht sich als ziemlich politische Aktion,
auch in Tradition von irgendwie dem weißen Fahrradplan von Anarchisten in Holland
aus den 60ern, wirklich öffentlichen, kostenlosen Fahrradnahverkehr für alle
zur Verfügung zu stellen.
Das heißt, die bieten Sticker an, Vorlagen auf der Webseite,
die man dann auf befreite Fahrräder kleben kann.
Von das ist jetzt kein Oberg mehr, sondern ein Libre-Bike.
Nutze es doch, teile es mit anderen und schließe es nicht ab.
Sie sind dafür da, mit allen geteilt zu werden. Wir unterstützen keinen Diebstahl.
Wenn du dir eins ausborgst, dann bitte verschließe es nicht,
zerstöre es nicht und bringe es nicht außer Reichweite von anderen.
Lass es einfach im öffentlichen Raum stehen, damit die nächste Person es benutzen kann.
Ja, und das wäre, das ist eigentlich so einfach, ne?
Wäre so einfach, wenn die Menschen das befolgen würden.
Ja, ich meine, man könnte sich ja eh überlegen, ob es nicht eine Investition
für die Stadt wäre, einfach mal Fahrräder zu kaufen und so lange in die Stadt
reinzupumpen, bis sie einfach genug da sind und dann hat immer jeder eins.
Fahrrad, Fahrräder zu fördern, ohnehin eine sehr sinnvolle Idee, ne?
Also ich meine, die Radläden würden wahrscheinlich anfangen.
Die Kutscher beschweren sich über die Fahrräder.
Ja, dann liegen die halt auch überall rum. Also es ist auch wieder mal so ein
etwas schwieriger Bereich.
Die machen dann die ganze Behandlung, die Fahrrädleinen für die Dinge.
Also ich finde das eine echt coole Idee.
Vor allem, ihr habt es ja erzählt, dass ihr das gerne nutzt.
Ich habe noch nie so ein Fahrrad benutzt, weil ich bin ein bisschen Aluhut-Nerd.
Also ich muss da in mir einen Account machen, ich muss da eine Kreditkarte angeben,
ich muss wahrscheinlich mit irgendeiner App Dann mich mit einer ID registrieren
und dann gibt es in irgendeinem Online-Dienst, in irgendeiner Cloud ein Bewegungsprofil in China.
Die hatten doch auch da ein Datenreichtum, so eins dieser Anbieter,
hat der Heise auch berichtet. war da die Datenbank weg und so.
Also da steht dann mein Bewegungsprofil, meine Kreditkarte, mein Real Name,
gebunden an die Telefonnummer oder so.
Deswegen habe ich sowas noch nie mitgebracht. So eine stadtweite,
freie Fahrradinitiative, Fahrradkommunismus für alle, wer sich eins nimmt.
Wer eins braucht, der nimmt sich eins, stellt es dann wieder hin,
statt irgendwie die längste Zeit das ohnehin angesperrt zu lassen,
nur weil man auf das Privateigentum steht. Fände ich eine echt coole Initiative.
Ähnlich wie fahrscheinloser Nahverkehr in ÖPNV.
Ja, das ist alles ein Problem. Nichtsdestotrotz ist es besser,
als wenn es diese Systeme nicht gäbe.
Wir müssen jetzt nur aufpassen, dass die Cops nicht bei Cloudflare einreiten
und da Server beschlagnahmen, weil da liegt nämlich diese LibreBike-Seite.
Nicht, dass das wieder Aufruf zu Straftaten ist oder sowas.
Ja, das muss man noch dazu sagen.
Auch hier rieche ich schon wieder eine interessante, angeregte Diskussion.
Jetzt aber wirklich zur letzten Sache.
Weil es wird Zeit.
Es wird Zeit. Und die einzige Frage, die sich stellt, ist, in welcher Zeitzone
und in welcher Zeit? Sommer oder Winter?
Es gibt eine öffentliche Konsultation zur Sommerzeitregelung,
die abgehalten wird von der EU.
Die gerne wissen möchte, wie denn wir oder ihr zur Sommerzeit stehen.
Und nach mehreren Tagen Dauerüberlastung funktioniert diese Seite jetzt.
Und da soll unter Umständen darüber entschieden, soll halt geprüft und bewertet
werden, ob man die derzeitigen Sommerzeitregelungen der EU beibehält oder ob man sie ändert.
Und André, was meinst du?
Ich bin für mehr Sommerzeit. Mein Problem mit der Umfrage ist,
Leute sind gegen Zeitumstellung,
aber denen ist es dann egal, welche Zeit ist quasi die wären auch zufrieden
damit wenn einfach das ganze Jahr über Winterzeit ist ich nenne das immer Dunkelzeit und ich hasse das,
für Spätaufsteher Leute, die nicht irgendwie schon 6 Uhr morgens aufstehen ist
Winterzeit echt gruselig irgendwie fällt auch noch damit zusammen, dass ohnehin,
die Tageslichtdauer sehr kurz ist wenn die,
Wenn die Standardzeit zur Winterzeit wird und die jetzt auch noch im Sommer
ist, dann bin ich da eigentlich gar nicht so gegen diese Zeitumstellung,
die nervt mich gar nicht so sehr.
Es ist aber natürlich eine Chance, wir könnten jetzt die Zeitumstellung abschaffen
und Sommerzeit zur Normalzeit machen, das wäre natürlich cool.
Dann wird es auch im Winter eine Stunde später hell, dann quasi um halb acht
oder so statt halb sieben.
Dafür aber nicht mehr, wann ist das hier dunkel im Winter, irgendwie halb fünf,
16.30 ist schon wieder kommst du aus der Arbeit und es ist schon dunkel,
wäre geil, wenn das eine Stunde später wäre.
Du möchtest die russische Lösung haben.
Ne, die russische Lösung haben wir da vorne schon, die haben neun Zeitzonen
und überall ist Moskau-Zeit und du musst das immer umrechnen.
Russland hatte bis vor mehreren Jahren, vor drei Jahren oder so,
auch Sommerzeit und Winterzeit hat es abgeschafft und ist bei Sommerzeit geblieben.
Ja, das wäre ja, wenn das dieses Outcome ist, dann bin ich zufrieden.
Wenn der Outcome ist über Winterzeit, dann bin ich lieber für die Zeitumstellung.
Also dazu muss man natürlich wissen, es gibt keine EU-einheitliche Zeitzone.
Auch wenn das irgendwie in dieser Umfrage so ein bisschen suggeriert wird,
wenn ich das richtig in Erinnerung habe.
Also da ist zumindest von einer EU-weiten Regelung die Rede.
Eine Regelung zur Sommerzeit.
Ja, zur Sommerzeit ist richtig. Genau. Also Also stimmt, darum geht es.
Auf jeden Fall, Tatsache ist, Finnland und die baltischen Länder,
Rumänien, Bulgarien, Griechenland sind plus zwei.
Zentraleuropa mit Ausnahme Portugal ist plus eins und eben Portugal,
UK, Irland und Island sind auf Greenwich Meantime.
Und einheitliche Zeit heißt ja auch von Polen bis Spanien also wenn man sozusagen auf Sommerzeit geht,
muss ich kurz nochmal nachdenken also Sommerzeit heißt wir schieben die Zeit
nach hinten wie man so schön sagt, es bleibt abends länger hell oder das helle heißt jetzt Abend,
das war alles eine Definitionssache,
dann verschiebt sich das natürlich in diesem kompletten Block Block.
Und das wäre für...
Warum muss denn diese Zeit innerhalb von Europa vereinheitlicht werden?
Also die Umstellung von einer Winterzeit auf eine Sommerzeit,
die muss auf jeden Fall einheitlich sein.
Weil das wäre nun der totale Terror, dass du was weiß ich, in Niedersachsen
hast du irgendwie noch Winterzeit, dann fährst du nach Holland und dann ist
da auf einmal Sommerzeit, da blickt ja keiner mehr durch.
Aber ich finde halt auch grundsätzlich hat sich einfach dieses Winterzeit-Sommerzeit-Modell
einfach komplett überholt, beziehungsweise war eigentlich noch nie eine richtig
gute Idee. Es gibt da ja verschiedene Mythen, warum das irgendwie alles mal
eingeführt werden soll.
Da gibt es irgendwie so diesen offiziellen Mythos mit dem Energiesparen,
weil wenn es ja länger hell ist und so weiter, das hat sich aber durch keine
Studie jemals belegen lassen.
Ganz im Gegenteil, der ganze Aufwand, den man damit hat, führt tendenziell eher
noch zu mehr Energieversorgung.
Wir kennen das alles aus der Computersystemadministration, da ist es die totale
Hölle, also dass ein Computer sozusagen,
dass derselbe Moment zweimal existiert, ja,
man sich das eben immer in diesen Umstellungszeiträumen dann eben doppelt merken
muss und Logfiles entsprechend anpassen muss, Software dann eben nicht aus der Spur geraten darf.
Das ist immer wieder total anstrengend und im Prinzip ist Sommerzeit,
Winterzeit einfach ein Ding, was weltweit fallen müsste und wenn die EU sich
da bewegt, dann kann ich mir auch durchaus vorstellen, dass das Welle macht
in andere Länder hinein.
Also Zeitzonen sind schon ein Problem, aber zumindest ist die Zeit klar und.
Sommerzeit und Winterzeit nervt einfach nur, bringt nix Winterzeit nervt Biorhythmus
durcheinander am Ende ist es ja auch egal welche Uhrzeit ist,
weil wenn du der Meinung bist, es ist noch nicht hell genug damit dein Laden aufmachen kann,
mein Gott dann machst du ihn halt später auf und hast länger offen Also man
hat ja auch die Flexibilität,
hier geht es ja darum die Synchronisation der Kernarbeitszeiten hinzubekommen
und zumindest übertragbare Meetingzeiten zu haben und dann ist es irgendwie
auch letztendlich egal wie man es nennt.
Wann Schulen anfangen und Behörden, das wird sich dadurch nicht ändern und da
fahren die Busfahrpläne, danach ist der öffentliche Tagesablauf,
so Kernzeit, danach kommt die Tagesschau und so,
das wird, ich meine, man hängt da schon auch von anderen Menschen ab,
nicht nur wann man seinen Laden aufmacht und sein Leben gestaltet.
Ja, was möchtest du gerne? Ich hätte gerne immer Sommerzeit.
Ja, aber was ist denn an der Sommerzeit jetzt?
Es ist abends länger hell, es ist nicht im Winter schon 16.30 Uhr dunkel, ich hasse das.
Es wäre doch mal gut, wenn es 17.30.
Uhr dunkel wäre.
Ist doch egal, wie die Uhr in der Nähe ist.
Wer im Dunkeln aufstehen will, kann das gerne machen. Ich will abends länger hell.
Genau.
Dass ich persönlich dann auch noch so lange schlafe, bis es hell wird,
ist meine persönliche...
Okay, wir halten fest, Sommerzeit und Winterzeit-Umstellung finden wir alle
doof. Die Nerds hätten es gerne länger hell.
Die Eltern werden vielleicht eine andere Position haben und die Schulen und so weiter.
Aber das ist ein anderes Thema, das werden wir jetzt ja auch nicht lösen.
Wir schreiben den Link zu dieser Konsultation der Europäischen Kommission in unsere Show Notes.
Falls ihr da meine Meinung vertretet, seid ihr herzlich eingeladen, daran teilzunehmen.
Ich habe auch noch einen netzpolitischen Aspekt. Die binden Google ein,
die EU-Kommission, und zwar Recapture, und haben das nicht in ihrer Datenschutzerklärung stehen.
Können wir gleich mit DSGVO Beschwerde machen.
Wenn die Konsultation nicht zu dem Ergebnis führt, was wir wollen,
dann können wir die platt machen.
Okay, super. Dann ist das Ding auf jeden Fall erstmal safe.
Zeitumstellung ungültig wegen DSGV.
So, damit wären wir dann bei den,
Terminen.
Am 27.07. feiert Systemly seine, ich glaube inzwischen jährlich stattfindende
Benefiz-Party im About-Blank-Systemly.
Ein Anbieter von E-Mail, Hosting, Jabba und Sonstigem für die Massen und kostenlos und frei.
Deswegen unterstützenswert. Die Party findet statt unter dem Motto Dance Like Nobody Is Watching.
In Berlin im Übrigen.
In Übrigen, habe ich gesagt.
Hast du gesagt?
Ja, im About Blank, aber nicht im übrigen.
Ach, ha, ha, ha, ha. Naja, aber wenn ich in Berlin feiern möchte,
hätte die Gelegenheit in der Nähe von Braunschweig, zwischen Braunschweig und,
Wolfsburg, genauer in Röttgesbüttel, das Hacken Open Air zu besuchen.
Feinstes Hackercamping, ausgerichtet vom Hackerspace Stratum 0 für Braunschweig
und Umgebung und ja, dort kann man basteln, diskutieren, grillen,
was man auf so einem Hacker-Open-Air eben so macht. Das findet statt vom 2.
Bis 5. August 2018 in Röttgesbüttel.
Dann gibt es noch vom 26.9. bis 3.10.
Wird geplant eine Privacy Week in Berlin stattfinden.
Ein vielfältiges Programm mit Vorträgen und Workshops, Kunst, Kultur ist geplant.
Man kann daran teilnehmen. Kontakt gibt es auf der Webseite,
und da ist also dann noch einmal nach Berlin geladen, um hier das Modell der
österreichischen, wienerischen Privacy Week ein bisschen zu kopieren.
Und wir fahren dann nach Wien oder was?
Die ist ja nicht zur gleichen Zeit, oder?
Nö, das nicht.
Wir fahren nach Wien und somit sei das jetzt hier auch empfohlen,
macht, dass sie passiert.
Ja, damit sind wir am Ende der Sendung angekommen.
Ja.
Privacy Weeks ohne Ende sozusagen.
Das ganze Jahr muss Privacy Weeks sein.
Privacy Year, das Jahr der Privatsphäre.
Das ist aber lange her, ne? Das Jahr der Privatsphäre.
Ja, das müssen wir einfach mal ausrufen. So was macht man heutzutage.
Es gibt ja, was weiß ich, den Tag der Büroklammer und der gewaschene Unterwäsche.
Tag des Borkenkäfers.
Ja, so macht man das einfach. Man ruft es einfach aus. Das könnte auch der CCC mal tun.
Zum Beispiel, dass man einfach sagt, das ist der internationale Tag des Schutzes der Privatsphäre.
Das ist einfach so. Das weiß man ja. Das ist ja auch schon immer so gewesen.
Und anlässlich dessen muss auf Arte eine entsprechende Dokumentation laufen
und bei ZDF und ARD eine Aktuelle Stunde einberufen werden oder im Bundestag.
Und ich fordere, dass zum internationalen Tag der Privatsphäre irgendwo in der
Pampa eine temporäre Funkzelle aufgebaut wird unter großem Pomp.
Ohne Vorratsdatenspeicherung die Privatsphäre zu schützen.
Und die Journalisten werden mit Bussen dahin gekarrt. Ohne WLAN.
So, damit sind wir am Ende dieses Desasters. des Desasters der diesigen Woche.
André, vielen herzlichen Dank, dass du uns mal wieder beehrt hast hier.
Danke euch.
Lustig war es. Tim bastelt jetzt weiter am Datenelch.
Libre Elch.
Libre Elch. Und ich danke Manuel, Tim, Das wäre doch nicht nötig gewesen.
Steffen sehr besonders und dem langjährigen Wiederholungstäter Bernd auch äußerst
besonders. Vielen herzlichen Dank.
Ja, ich danke auch allen Leuten, die sich an der tollen neuen Aktion 1001 Tower-Aufträge
für die Meta-Ebene beteiligen.
Ist das so? Ja, habe ich in der letzten Freakshow mal etwas ausführlicher dargelegt,
wie sich das alles so mit Hörerzahlen und Supporterquoten und so weiter verhält.
Da werde ich auch noch mal was zu bloggen.
Die letzte Freakshow habe ich noch gar nicht gehört, weil da war ja hoher Besuch.
Da war ja hoher Besuch. Die habe ich mir aufbewahrt, extra nicht zum Einschlafen hören.
Monkeydom, ne? Genau. Lange nicht gesehen, weil der war ja weg gewesen.
Genau, bei Äpfel Computing.
Und hat in der Sendung dann auch mal ausführlich berichtet, wie es so ist,
bei Äpfel Computing und in den USA der Neuzeit so zu arbeiten.
Ist er wenigstens aus sympathischen politischen Gründen wieder gegangen?
Es gab eine Gemengelage an Gründen, die ihn letzten Endes zur Rückkehr bewogen haben.
Okay, bin ich sehr gespannt. auf die Sendung. Also Monkeydom und Neutrinos aus
der Meta-Ebene und dazu der Aufruf uns zumindest einen Daten-Elch zu spenden.
Der Tim hat einen kleinen Landsitz.
Wenn der da nicht reinpasst, dann machen wir das bei Clemens und der Clemens
baut auf jeden Fall schön Daten-Elchen.
Treibt die Elche zu Clemens, der baut sie zu Daten-Elchen um und treibt sie
dann durch die brandenburgische Pampa.
Und wenn der Daten-Elch leer ist, wird er wieder aufgeladen von Clemens am Supercharger.
Das ist schon wieder los.